bon j'ai pas
tout comme
être de la slide je me suis permis de
raccourcir un tout petit peu le titre
qui figurait sur la fiche mais enfin
j'espère ne pas avoir totalement
travesti le titre qui vous a fait venir
ici
s'ils tentaient que vous ayez prêter
attention à ce que je vais essayer de
vous dire cet après midi au fond c'est
de façon un peu simple si j'y arrive un
peu illustré ça je suis sûr d'y arriver
même si tu en entends j'utiliserai des
graphiques un peu compliqué le bout d'un
chemin personnel qui m'a amené à penser
qu'aujourd'hui on était rentrés dans une
tentative de résoudre un problème avec
des outils qui sont pas adaptés pour ça
et en fait la réponse
pour ceux d'entre vous qui sont très
pressés qui ont un train à prendre où
leur chef qui leur fait les gros yeux la
réponse à la question posée ici ou
est-ce que c'est compatible la réponse
est non c'est pas compatible
voilà donc vous pouvez repartir au
revoir monsieur d'armes et pour ceux qui
ont un peu de temps pour rester je vais
essayer d'être un tout petit peu plus
précis dans l'énoncé de cette réponse
vous avez tous j'imagine entendu parler
des objectifs du développement sur des
objectifs du développement durable alors
développement durable qui n'a jamais
entendu cette expression dans la salle
c'était une personne ne parle pas
français et qui n'ont donc vous avez
tous entendu parler du développement
durable alors le développement durable
s'est appliqué à nos problèmes cette
petite blague qu'on fait sur les couples
à vous savez le mariage c'est l'art de
ne pas résoudre à 2 des problèmes qu'on
se posait pas quand on était tout seul
eh bien le développement durable c'est
finalement l'art de ne pas arriver à
résoudre ensemble 17 problème dont on
sait même pas résoudre les problèmes
unitaire pris un par un voilà c'est un
peu ça finalement le développement
durable je vous ai mis ici les dix sept
objectifs du développement durable tels
que ça sort de l'assemblée enfin des
nations unies plus exactement alors
c'est génial c'est génial il y en a pour
tout le monde
les économistes sont contents nous pib
croît forever les médecins sont contents
les gens vont de mieux en mieux
les profs sont contents parce que tout
le monde est de plus en plus avant etc
etc donc vous en avez pour tout le monde
les industriels
ellul et c'est enfin je voulais rajoute
tout cela donc ils sont tous contents
c'est vermelho le développement durable
c'est l'art de dire à tout le monde
qu'on va résoudre tous les problèmes en
même temps c'est exactement ça le
développement durable alors
malheureusement ça ne va pas marcher
cissé durable ça sera sûrement pas du
développement au sens où on l'entend
pour un certain nombre de ses objectifs
et cissé transitoirement du
développement au sens où on l'entend
pour un de ces hauts de la fin pour une
partie de ses objectifs ça sera sûrement
pas durable c'est ça le gros problème et
même sustainable au sens anglais du
terme
malheureusement on n'est pas parti pour
les avoir en fait on pourrait avoir tout
ça dans un même ensemble si c'était
comme disent les statisticiens co
intégrée c'est-à-dire que si on avait un
même déterminant qui soit capable de
produire ses 17 cause en parallèle
d'accord ça ça marcherait mais vous
allez voir que en pratique ce n'est pas
le cas alors pour vous montrer que en
pratique ce n'est pas le cas on va
passer par un professeur beaucoup plus
connu que moi enfin maintenant il a pris
sa retraite je crois mais qui officiait
jusqu'à il ya un an ou deux à la
télévision une fois par mois
alors il est beaucoup plus connu que moi
puisque à chaque fois que il officiait
il avait 10 % des français dans sa salle
de classe respect je pense pas qu'il y
ait beaucoup d'enseignants ici qui
arrive à ce niveau là même avec un mook
extraordinaire et voilà la question
qu'il nageait que j'ai jamais vu poser
en tout cas les quelques fois où je les
regardais mais qu'il aurait pu poser en
lien avec le sujet qui nous occupe cet
après midi alors soit dit en passant si
vous posez cette question aux gens qui
s'occupent de l'énergie dans les chais
les hauts fonctionnaires ou bien chez
les personnages politiques dont vous
avez un élu qu'il s'occupe de l'énergie
ou un ministre qui s'occupe de l'énergie
dans beaucoup d'endroits si vous lui
demandez
ce que c'est que l'énergie je suis
raisonnablement prêt à parier une petite
partie de mes économies avec qui veut
que il va pas vous donner la bonne
réponse
non il va pas vous donner la bonne
réponse alors si vous interrogez un
français pris au hasard sur c'est quoi
l'énergie alors il ya une première
réponse qui ne sera pas l'objet de ma
dissertation maintenant qui essai
nucléaire
mais en fait c'est pas ça que je veux
dire la deuxième chose qui va venir alou
la première ça dépend des gens qui va
venir à l'esprit de n'importe qui quand
on demande c'est quoi l'énergie c'est
c'est une facture l'énergie c'est un
truc qui se paye c'est un truc qui
s'achètent comme une paire de chaussures
ou comme un fauteuil donc de temps en
temps j'achète de l'énergie ça se
matérialise par le fait que mon
fournisseur d'électricité m'envoie une
facture parce qu'en général c'est
l'électricité qui vient en premier
en deuxième que mon fournisseur de gaz
m'envoie une facture si vraiment je suis
bien réveillé ce matin là après trois
tasses de café pas plus me paraît que
c'est mauvais pour la santé
eh bien je penserai éventuellement au
plein à la pompe à essence mais ça déjà
c'est un peu osé
donc les premiers trucs qui me viennent
à l'esprit c'est une facture alors le
problème c'est que si vous raisonnez
comme ça vous avez perdu
vous avez perdu parce que quand vous
regardez ce que vaut l'énergie dans la
totalité des factures que nous avons à
régler il ya une manière de caractériser
cette fraction c'est de dire eh bien
c'est la fraction de ce que les gens
gagnent donc le pib qui est consacré à
des achats d'énergie et bien vous voyez
que les très mauvaises à néant par
exemple au niveau des chocs pétroliers
qu'un certain nombre de cheveux gris
dans la salle entièrement connu ça peut
monter jusqu'à 8 9 10% de ce que on paye
mais enfin les bonnes années ça descend
à quelques pour cent seulement si je
prends les hydrocarbures
donc si l'énergie est vu comme étant une
facture
à ce moment on va rentrer dans un
mécanisme évident d'allocations d'une
ressource rare qui s'appelle notre temps
et donc je veux dire voilà c'est 5 % de
ce que je paye donc je vais y consacrer
5 % de mon temps ou 5 % des élus ou 5 %
de n'importe quoi
de l'argent que je dépense après je vois
5 % d'accord donc ça va sûrement pas
être quelque chose qui va conditionner
tout le reste de ce que je fais et sur
lequel je vais investir des moyens
absolument considérable pour comprendre
ce que ça veut 5 % de ce que je paye ça
mérite 5 % de mon temps mon loyer c'est
quand même un autre sujet d'accord
or malheureusement ce que je vais vous
montrer un peu plus tard c'est que ce
genre de raisonnement est opérant si
vous avez des dépenses qui sont
indépendantes les unes des autres
dit autrement si ce que vous dépensez en
énergie ne change pas ce que vous
dépensez en loyer vous avez raison ce
réseau des comme ça mais dans un monde
dans lequel la disponibilité énergétique
c'est ça je vais expliquer dans pas
longtemps conditionne tout le reste de
la machine économique
ça n'a pas plus de sens de raisonner
comme ça que si vous dites votre
cervelle ces 2 % de votre poids et donc
vous pouvez vous en occupez 2 % du temps
et le résultat c'est pas la peine
d'accord vous pouvez l'oxygéner 2 % du
temps où l'otan le résultat c'est pas la
peine
ou si vous en perdez la moitié et bien
vous diminuez votre efficacité globale
de 1% c'est vraiment pas grave no big
deal passons au sujet suivant
c'est toute la différence entre le
raisonnement légitime quand on a des
parts de camembert qui ne dépendent pas
les unes des autres et le raisonnement
qui devient totalement illégitime quand
les parts de camembert dépend des unes
des autres
alors un autre une autre claque notre
black pardon classique dans l'économie
c'est de dire l'agriculture c'est 2% du
pib donc on peut s'en passer
si vous mangez pas en quelques mois le
reste du pib va commencer à avoir l'air
un peu bancal d'accord donc le l'idée
que comme ça on regarde départ de
camembert et ça suffit à avoir un
jugement sur l'importance qu'il convient
d'accorder malheureusement l'indicateur
économique n'a pas été fait pour ça donc
mauvaise réponse
après il ya une deuxième catégorie
d'acteurs dans cette affaire chez qui le
réflexe pavlovien
c'est pas de dire que l'énergie c'est
quelque chose qui coûte pas cher et donc
on s'en fout encore que dès que ça monte
on s'en fout un peu moins mais peu
importe c'est de dire qu'il faut
l'économiser
vous avez aussi tous entendu l'économie
et notre bien le plus précieux
économisons là etc
deuxième erreur ou deuxième choses
fausses si vous êtes en ce moment dans
cette salle à avoir le temps de
m'écouter et avoir eu le temps de faire
des études pour bosser à la fac
au lieu d'être occupés à ramasser des
patates et d'avoir la vie du paysan
grenoble ou à dire un siècle
c'est justement parce qu'on n'a pas
économisé l'énergie c'est justement
parce qu'on s'est vautré avec délice
dans l'abondance énergétique pendant
maintenant 2 afin de manière croissante
sur les deux derniers siècles
que nous avons réussi à mettre au
travail des machines qui bosse à votre
place et qui récoltent les doigts
grenoblois de votre place et puis tout
serait plus tout le reste
eux et qu'il faut que vous vous avez le
temps de travailler du chapeau comme moi
ainsi que tous les gens qui ne
travaillent plus dans l'extraction de
l'énergie primaire de l'environnement
c'est-à-dire l'agriculture c'est
justement parce qu'on s'est vautré dans
l'énergie depuis deux siècles que existe
la civilisation dite avancée est en fait
ce qu'on considère être le progrès
scientifique en fait ne serait rien sans
la capacité à diffuser c'est à dire
l'énergie qui vont vous avez un type
génial mais vous n'avez pas une
invention géniale pour passer par
personne donc deuxième mauvaise réponse
alors en fait aujourd'hui ça en devient
une bonne parce que l'univers est en
train de devenir contre un mais très
longtemps ça n'a pas été la bonne en
fait quand on pour l'essentiel des gens
tout le monde s'en fout c'est à dire que
la quasi totalité des gens c'est même
pas sur leurs écrans radar l'énergie ce
qui est sur leurs écrans radar c'est le
chômage
c'est est-ce qu'ils vont réussir à
boucler leurs fins de mois c'est etc
c'est ce que je vais réussir à me marier
ou pas est-ce que je vais divorcer ou
pas en fait c'était absolument pas d
voilà donc la majeure partie des gens
comme lui ils réfléchissent pas beaucoup
ils ont en fait pas beaucoup d'avis et
puis vous pouvez demander un poète est
en fait le poète va vous donner la bonne
réponse
le poète va vous dire l'énergie c'est ce
dont je suis rempli un matin où je suis
en forme et bien en fait le poète viens
de vous donner la bonne réponse
l'énergie puisqu'il ya une noble
assemblée de physiciens dans cette salle
enfin au moins pour partie vous vous
rappellerez que enfin en tout cas c'est
comme ça que moi je suis capable de le
résumer en une phrase c'est la grandeur
qui caractérise de changement d'état
d'un système donc l'énergie
c'est par définition la capacité à
organiser les flux dans le monde qui
nous entoure
c'est par définition la capacité à
changer le monde physiquement après
derrière on peut mettre toutes les
contreparties qu'on veut d euros 11,6
une affaire de conventions humaine par
contre ce qui n'est pas une affaire de
conventions humaine c'est le fait que
l'énergie c'est la capacité à organiser
le monde qui nous entoure et donc
effectivement plus on a des énergies
plus on a de capacité à court terme a
piloté le monde qui nous entoure et
c'est bien ça qui nous a intéressé
depuis la nuit des temps dans le fait
d'être capable de domestique est de plus
en plus de sources d'énergie
c'est très exactement pour ça qu'on a
cherché à le faire c'est très exactement
pour ça que ce qu'on la paye c'est pas
le sujet le vrai sujet c'est combien on
en a et vous verrez qu a pas de lien
entre les deux et c'est très exactement
pour ça que on ne l'a pas économiser
jusqu'à maintenant parce que encore une
fois plus on en consomme plus on est
capable d'organiser une grande quantité
de flux par personne autour de nous il
est très exactement c'est à l'énergie
alors une fois que je vous ai dit ça je
vous ai pas encore donné toute la
réponse là aussi dans cette noble
assemblée de physiciens vous vous
rappelez que l'énergie à quelques lois
qui comme vient de le rappeler
magistralement nicolas hulot à qui il
faut rendre un hommage appuyé ne peuvent
pas se modifier par un vote à
l'assemblée nationale veut pas dire je
propose aux députés d'invalider la loi
de conservation de l'énergie ça serait
quand même plus pratique pour tenir mes
promesses électorales enfin vous pouvez
mais ça vaut ce que vaut un vote à
l'assemblée à ce moment qui a toutes les
chances de ne pas se réaliser
alors jeudi un hommage appuyé à nicolas
parce que ce qu'il vient de faire il ya
pas longtemps ses parts à cause du
nucléaire que c'est important ce qui
vient de faire ça on s'en fout femme
s'en fout c'est secondaire
nicolas ils viennent dire un truc qui
est absolument capital il vient
justement de dire vous ne pouvez pas
violer les faits par un vote à
l'assemblée nationale voilà ce qui donc
maintenant nous sommes dans un monde
dans lequel si vous essayez de tenir
enfin de promettre alors que les faits
sont contre vous dans l'ethnie la
promesse ni la confiance des gens qui
vous élisent j'ai tout perdu et il dit
par ailleurs dans un monde contre un
vous êtes obligé de choisir
donc il va falloir mettre les prime dans
l'ordre et si vous pouvez pas tous les
traiter en même temps vous allez devoir
choisir
et comme disait le poète choisir c'est
renoncer donc le donc en ce qui concerne
la physique j'en reviens il ya une loi
la loi de conservation qui fait que en
fait consommer de l'énergie
ça ne peut rien être d'autre que de
l'extraire de l'environnement où elles
se trouvent déjà parce que nous n'avons
pas la capacité nous les hommes à créer
de l'énergie ex nihilo corps l'humanité
en son sein ne peut pas créer de
l'énergie tout ce qu'elle peut faire
c'est exploiter à son profit une énergie
qui existe déjà dans l'environnement et
l'exploiter ça veut dire la faire passer
dans un convertisseur qui va être
capable de la transformer c'est ça en
fait consommer de l'énergie
alors historiquement le seul
convertisseur qu'on a eu à notre
disposition c'est de nous mêmes et la
seule énergie qu'on savait mettre dans
le convertisseur en question ces trucs
qui se mange je reste la définition un
truc qui se mange c'est un truc qui
recèle de l'énergie potentielle et que
vous mettez dans votre grand gargamel
voilà tel gargantua et à ce moment vous
êtes capable de mouvoir vos bras et vos
jambes et accessoirement de vous
maintenir à 37 degrés pour utiliser une
autre forme d'énergie que ce qui se
mange
eh bien il faut utiliser un autre
convertisseur est très souvent on a
assimilé historiquement la découverte du
convertisseur avec la capacité à le
diffuser à tout le monde donc on a tenu
pour acquis que quand on le découvre
tout le monde est capable de s'en servir
et c'est pour ça qu'on dit c'est le
progrès scientifique qui améliorent la
qualité de vie des gens non le progrès
scientifique permet de comprendre
comment on fait la machine mais sans
énergie vous la fait pas et voulait
diffuser par tout le monde
le progrès ne permet que de
conceptualiser les choses il ne permet
absolument pas de la réaliser pour ça
vous avez besoin d'énergie plus
exactement vous avez besoin que
l'environnement soit toujours
suffisamment généreux avec vous pour
être capable de diffuser votre
trouvaille géniale et donc utiliser de
plus en plus d'énergie en pratique ça ne
veut pas dire que vous mangez de plus en
plus en face ils vous pouvez essayer
mais il ya quand même une limite à la
faire en fait utiliser de plus en plus
d'énergie il faut le comprendre et pour
toute la suite ça va être absolument
capital comme vous utilisez un parc de
machines de plus en plus important c'est
ça que ça veut dire utiliser de plus en
plus d'énergie alors le parc de machines
de plus en plus important peut être une
chaudière de plus en plus grosse parce
que votre appartement les plus en plus
gros qui aurait lui même été construit
avec des grues plus en plus grosse et
des cimenteries de plus en plus grosse
et des camions plus en plus gros ou bien
c'est que vous avez une diversité de
machines à votre disposition qui
augmente donc c'est soit la taille soit
la nature mais utiliser de plus en plus
d'énergie ça veut donc dire que le parc
de machines à votre disposition est de
plus en plus important parce que encore
une fois vous ne buvez pas le pétrole
enfin je voulais qu'on salisse pas
terrible ne respirait pas le gaz sauf
l'hélium pour avoir la voix de donald à
et vous ne mangez pas le charbon sauf
aux quatre là tu ans donc d'une manière
générale l'énergie encore une fois quand
vous la consommer c'est que vous la
donner à manger à une machine qui va
obéir à vos ordres
c'est ça que ça veut dire consommer de
l'énergie
l'énergie qui est aujourd'hui absorbée
par le parc de machines est sans commune
mesure avec l'énergie qui étaient
absorbés par notre organisme
alors pour ça je vais prendre une petite
comparaison désolé pour ceux d'entre
vous qui l'ont déjà vu 20 fois bienvenue
au 21e enfin aux autres qui consiste à
comparer l'énergie vous êtes capable de
restituer avec votre propre carcasse et
l'énergie aujourd'hui mis en jeu par le
premier vélo solex venue alors on va
imaginer pour vous c'est facile que vous
alliez faire un petit tour dans la
chartreuse et s'il ya des parisiens
exilés par ici qu'ils ne sont jamais
allés dans la chartreuse
imaginez que vous montiez six fois sur
la tour eiffel avant le petit déjeuner
on est à peu près sur les mêmes ordres
de grandeur à pied un pas dans
l'ascenseur à ce moment je prends 90
kilos parce que c'est simple pour le
calcul que je vais faire alors je fais
tout simplement e galleg ghc un peu faux
comme calcul parce que quand vous faites
un pas vous fait un petit truc comme ça
donc
mais pour peu importe l'ordre de
grandeur est bon donc vous montez fait
2000 mètres de dénivelé est bien égale
mgh vous dit que la quantité d'énergie
core of fourni votre carcasse
c'est un ridicule demi kilowattheures
d'énergie mécanique même à ridicule
estime demi kilowattheures d'énergie
mécanique
alors pour ceux d'entre vous dans la
salle s'il y en a qui sont pas familiers
des kilowattheure a admis kilowattheure
ces 20 minutes de fonctionnement de
votre lave-vaisselle d'accord pour vous
donner une petite une petite idée mais
je viendrai après sur des ordres de
grandeurs eux
bon ça vous allez quand même un peu
transpirer si vous faites ça et si on
imagine que vous faites ça un jour sur
deux donc un jour vous vous reposez un
jour vous faites de 1000 mètres dans la
chartreuse
un jour vous reposez vous avez un patron
sympa vous pouvez chercher qu'un jour
sur deux et bien à ce moment à la fin de
l'année vous aurez fournit une énergie
mécanique avec votre corps qui se monte
à 100 kilowatts heure accor dont vous
êtes capables de transformer
l'environnement puisque l'énergie c'est
la transformation
si vous utilisez vos propres muscles à
hauteur de 100 kilowatts heure par an et
par personne si vous utilisez vos jambes
si monsieur schwarzenegger utilise ses
bras qui sont presque aussi gros que vos
jambes
pas tout à fait quand il était jeune et
que vous pelleter un grand trou enfin la
terre plus exactement pour faire un
grand trou donc là mon calcul c'est que
j'ai imaginé que vous des caissiers 15
tonnes de
hier dans la journée pas mal ça vous
faire mal au dos aux siens et que vous
la remontée d'un mètre ça va aussi vous
faire des ampoules
toujours est il que égale mgh me dis
qu'à la fin de la journée vous est dix
fois plus ridicule que la personne qui
va dans la chartreuse
puisque vous avez restituer 0,05
kilowattheures d'énergie mécanique
véhicule totalement ridicule
si vous faites ça un jour sur deux
pareils 10 kilowatts heure d'énergie
mécanique à la fin de l'année et bien 10
kilowatts heure
c'est pas en énergie mécanique mais en
énergie thermique
c'est le contenu énergétique de la
combustion d'un litre de pétrole
un litre de pétrole dont je rappelle que
dans notre pays tout nucléaire
vous savez évidemment qu'on est dans un
pays tout nucléaire chaque français
consomme de l'ordre de 1000 litres par
an
ah tiens on serait pas que 'tout
nucléaire' nom n'est pas tout nucléaire
du tout les françaises sont aussi très
très pétrole comme beaucoup tous les
pays occidentaux et donc on consomme
mille litres de pétrole alors quand je
dis mille litres c'est pas juste dans
les voitures c'est dans les voitures
dans les avions de chauffage au fuel
dans l'industrie et dans la fabrication
des matières plastiques
mais tous confondus ramené à la tête de
pipe on est à mille litres donc dans un
litre de pétrole g 10 kilowatts heure
d'énergie thermique que très souvent je
ne vais pas utilisé comme tel je vais la
mettre dans un moteur à combustion
interne pour en retirer de l'énergie
mécanique alors là il ya l'afrique
arnaud qui passe par là et qui me dit tu
auras pas 10 kilowatts heure d'énergie
mécanique même si tu me demande
gentiment tu en auras 2 à 4 voilà mais
c'est quand même pas mal parce que ça
veut dire que dans 1 litre d'essence qui
vaut la somme scandaleusement chair d'un
peu plus d'un euro en ce moment eh bien
j'ai la même capacité à transformer
l'environnement que dans 10 jours de
travail de force d'une personne qui
utilise ses jambes et 100 jours de
utilise ses bras un litre de pétrole que
je vais payer scandaleusement cher mais
enfin pas tout à fait quand même le même
prix que le travail en question si je
paye le travailleur en question au
salaire minimum en france
vous savez qu'en ce moment on essaye de
trouver des tas d'astuces pour ne plus
le payer au salaire minimum mais peu
importe je le paye au salaire minimum
d'ordre de grandeur reste le même à ce
moment aussi tout ce qui m'intéresse
c'est le travailleur en question c'est
sa puissance mécanique et bien je vais
payer mon kilowattheures d'énergie
mécanique de quelques centaines d'euros
à quelques milliers d'euros
quelques centaines d'euros à quelques
milliers d'euros alors qu'en face la
machine va me rendre le même service
pour un coût marginal de 10 centimes en
ordre de grandeur
dit autrement quand je passe de l'homme
à la machine pour transformer
physiquement l'environnement dans une
société occidentale
aujourd'hui eh bien je renchérit le coût
d'une transformation unitaire pardon je
diminue le coût d'une transformation
unitaire de quelques centaines à
quelques milliers
évidemment à ce prix là j'ai pas
l'intelligence pas encore me diront les
plus optimistes des technologiques mais
par contre en ce qui concerne la
transformation physique
j'ai un rapport qui est totalement à
battable totalement imbattable même si
je prends quelqu'un que je ne paye pas
ce qui est totalement interdit par
toutes les conventions en vigueur donc
mais imaginons quand même qu'on prenne
quelqu'un qu'on ne paye pas qui
s'appelle un esclave
alors comme c'est rarement quelque chose
que l'on fait de très bon coeur être
esclave
si vous avez un esclave employés à votre
service en général il va avoir été
transbahuter là où il doit travailler
contre son gré ce qui va coûter de
l'argent il doit être maintenue en vie
ce qui coûte de l'argent on doit
l'empêcher de vous trucider et fiche le
camp ce qui coûte de l'argent et bien si
vous mettez boutabout tous ses coups
parlons pas de morale pour le moment
parlant juste de coûts eh bien vous vous
rendez compte que même un esclave
ça va vous coûter 10 à 100 fois ce que
vous coûte la machine l'esclave
comme je le disais n'a pas envie de
rester esclave a envie de [ __ ] le camp
et envie de vite russie dès la machine
ne se met pas en grève n'est pas
syndiquée à la cgt bossage 24 et lé 10 à
100 fois plus productives
la raison pour laquelle l'esclavagé a
disparu vous l'avez l'arrêt ça s'appelle
le pétrole votre code génétique
désolé de le dire même mieux
intentionnés d'entre vous est très
exactement le même que celui des
esclavagistes dia de siècle très
exactement le même
ce qui fait que vous vous êtes pas
esclavagiste alors que il l'était c'est
tout simplement que les conditions
environnantes sont différentes
t'es juste sans la différence vous
n'êtes pas foncièrement meilleurs qu'eux
ils font sûrement pillards du reste
nîmois nous sommes très exactement les
mêmes avec les mêmes qualités et les
mêmes travers
simplement aujourd'hui ça n'a plus aucun
sens de s'emmerder à avoir des esclaves
alors que je le redis la machine qui ne
protestent pas contre sa condition de
machines et qui est 10 à 100 fois plus
performante et là pour le remplacer
alors une fois je vous ai dit tout ça je
vais maintenant passé une première fois
à l'économie j'y reviendrai je veux
faire des allers retours entre les deux
mais je vais passer une première fois à
l'économie
je vais vous faire maintenant un cours
d'économie physique donc au début je
vais pas parler d'euros je vais juste
vous dire l'économie au fond c'est un
système de transformation
d'accord c'est quoi l'économie c'est je
prends des ressources dans
l'environnement et je les transforme
pour faire autre chose ce que vous avez
dans cette salle ça n'est que des
ressources transformé pour faire autre
chose
d'accord on a trouvé dans
l'environnement des minerais du bois qui
a poussé tout seul et c'est bien à fait
autre chose alors les ressources que je
trouve dans l'environnement
donc là vous avez la terre stylisé
neutre est très utilisé pour être
populaire
je vais les mettre dans deux catégories
distinctes
il ya la catégorie de ceux qui ne se
renouvelle pas à l'échelle des
civilisations humaines
alors ce que je vais trouver là dedans
c'est les minerais métalliques ou les
mines de phosphate ou les mines de
potasse ou la biodiversité puisque
recréer des espèces à l'échelle d'une
vie humaine c'est compliqué et
évidemment les combustibles fossiles sur
lesquelles je reviendrai un peu plus
tard et puis j'ai également des
ressources qui se renouvelle pour lui
qu'on leur fiche la paix donc là dedans
je mets tout ce qui pousse rapidement
donc une bonne partie des plantes des
végétaux etc
la lumière du soleil qui nous arrive
donc ça c'est le capital de départ et il
se trouve que ce capital de départ
j'y reviendrai aussi plus tard il est
gratuit c'est à dire que ce que notre
mère nature a fait en 14 milliards
d'années d'évolution depuis le big bang
enfin 13,7 je crois aux dernières
nouvelles et bien vous n'avez pas payé
un centime pour ça donc mère-nature
après le big bang a pris les protons en
a fait dans une première génération des
toiles tous les éléments du tableau de
mendeleïev 0 si vous essayez de refaire
ça sur terre ça coûte un bras
du reste il ya peut-être des gens ici
qui s'essaye à ce genre d'exercice et
ils sont pas au bout de leurs peines
ensuite mr nature avec le tableau de
mendeleïev a fait une planète terre a
laissé
cuisiner la planète terre avec une
atmosphère pendant quelques milliards
d'années ça vous a fait 30 millions
d'espèces ou 40 ou 50 enfin peu importe
ça vous a fait un océan ça vous a fait
un système climatique qui était stable
depuis dix mille ans avoue étaient trois
héros kratos tout ça low cost d'accord
tout ça est gratuit j'incite tout ça est
gratuit est essentielle mais gratuit
c'est justement le problème sur lequel
on va tomber plus tard essentiel mais
gratuit et puis arrive les hommes pas
gratuits ou des fois alors les hommes
qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire dans cette
histoire
ils vont aller servir dans ce grand
supermarché que mère nature a mis à
l'heure où père nature ma mère nature
c'est plus sympa a mis à leur
disposition en 14 milliards d'années de
dur labeur ils vont prendre se servir
et puis de temps en temps ils vont se
dire il ya des trucs si je les
transforme par mon travail c'est plus
sympa à l'arrivée d'accord pour chasser
je peux essayer au pour vous pour
chasser je peux essayer de transpercer
ma proie avec un 1 core de serre brut
m'enfin ça marche moins bien que si je
taille donc je vais travailler un peu je
vais le thaï et puis ça va mieux marcher
donc les hommes vont aller chercher des
ressources dans l'environnement pour en
faire des ressources transformé qui vont
leur rendre un service plus importants
que ceux qui l'ont trouvé dans
l'environnement taille des silex et
c'est alors au début les hommes sont pas
très nombreux et pas très productif donc
tout ce qu'ils peuvent prendre dans la
partie ressources renouvelables au
premier ordre
ça touche quand même pas trop les
ressources renouvelables encore qu'il ya
un débat sur la mégafaune en amérique du
nord si ma mémoire est bonne mais bon
peu importe il t'a ils servent et
globalement
la nature et bodmer elle renouvelle par
contre dès que vous tapez dans les
ressources non renouvelables
le stocks commencent à baisser alors au
début c'est imperceptible mais il
n'empêche que le stock commence à
baisser
et puis un jour les hommes découvrent
qu'ils peuvent utiliser à leur profit de
l'énergie extracorporelle donc tout à
l'heure je vous ai montré les machines
enfin avant l'aîné machine il ya eu le
vent qui poussait les bateaux il ya eu
les animaux de trait etc je vous
rappelle soit dit en passant je
reviendrai aussi qu' il ya deux siècles
nous étions 100 % venayre donc le fait
qu'on puisse faire un monde 100% weider
ne pose pas le moindre problème on sait
faire à cette époque là il y avait 500
millions d'agriculteurs 30 ans
l'espérance de vie à la naissance mais
on sait faire
il ya aucun problème sur le fait qu'on
sait faire avec une espèce humaine qu'on
sache refaire avec 7 milliards
d'individus vivant comme vous vouliez
aujourd'hui ça c'est un sujet de débat
il y aura je suis pas sûr de parier mon
argent sur le fait qu'on va y arriver
mais qu'on sache faire sans
contreparties imposées sur le nombre de
bons hommes leur espérance de vie et
leur niveau de vie j'ai aucun doute là
dessus atelier aucun doute donc les
hommes découvrent l'énergie extra
corporelle et grâce à l'énergie
extracorporelle ils vont pouvoir
extraire de manière plus rapide
les ressources de l'environnement elle
est transformé de manière plus rapide
puisqu'il perdit met au travail
d'autres choses d'autres convertisseurs
d'énergie que donc je le dis les animaux
de trait bateaux à voile etc
et puis il découvre également nos braves
hommes que ils ont la possibilité
d'utiliser la production de l'année pour
augmenter la production de l'année
suivante ce que les économistes vont
appeler le capital c'est à dire c'est
une production qui est faite de la même
manière que les biens de consommation
courante par exemple cet immeuble il est
fait de la même manière que les biens de
consommation courante vous allez
chercher des ressources dans
l'environnement et voulait transformer
pour faire un truc qui vous intéressent
ce que fait recours dans une carrière ça
vous protège pas de la pluie alors que
faire cours dans un immeuble sis alors
déjà que les étudiants ils ont tendance
à s'endormir dans les salles de classe
les carrières je vous raconte pas non
pardon
donc le sait exactement pareil sauf que
cet immeuble ne se détruit pas quand on
s'en sert enfin normalement alors qu'un
certain nombre de biens de consommation
courante oui mais le processus de
production physique est exactement le
même
alors les hommes se disent tout ça est
vachement bon on en profite youplaboum
et puis le fait qu'ils aient cette
abondance de ressources procurées par
l'abondance énergétique améliorent leur
qualité de vie sarah meier leur
espérance de vie déjà et ça améliore
leur qualité de vie et du coup ils
deviennent de plus en plus nombreux
puisque 10 mais ça marche donc comme
disait coluche un temps je gagne je joue
donc ils continuent à jouer et il tape
de plus en plus violemment
et puis un jour les hommes sont devenus
tellement nombreux et tellement
productif par personne que le stock de
ressources renouvelables qui jusque là
était resté à peu près intact parce que
le flux de prélèvement rester inférieure
au potentiel de renouvellement se met
lui aussi à baisser et donc
disparaissent les baleines une partie
des poissons une partie des espèces une
partie des forêts etc commencé à baisser
et puis dans cette activité d briller
les hommes créer des sous produits
indésirables qui s'appelle la pollution
donc en gros la pollution c'est tout ce
qu'ils nous emmerdent c'est tous les
trucs qu'on n'a jamais demandé mais qui
arrive à l'occasion de notre activité de
transformation parce que quand vous
transformez pas vous séparer ce que vous
aviez en entrée en deux catégories ce
qui vous intéresse et ce qui vous
intéresse pas ce qui vous intéresse
s'appelle la production ce qui nous
intéresse pas s'appelle la pollution en
groupe et cette pollution si je l'a
traduit en des termes techniques
en fait elle vient affaiblir la qualité
des actifs naturels restant votre
rivière polluée à moins de capacité à
fournir des services y compris aux
hommes qu une rivière en bonne étant une
atmosphère transformer à moins de
capacité à fournir aux hommes un climat
stable que une atmosphère en bon état et
c'est donc la pollution seat large
le fait que vous allez amoindrir la
qualité des actifs naturels restant donc
voilà l'activité humaine exprimé en flux
et en termes de bilan d'
actif passif c'est à dire que dans cette
affaire j'ai transformé des ressources
plus toujours la même quantité d'atomes
de cuivre sur terre je les ai pas
transmuter enfin je crois pas et ils
sont simplement passer des mines des
mines où ils étaient avant
dans tous les autres tous les moteurs
électriques que vous utilisez
aujourd'hui voilà et au passage j'ai
polluée j'ai fait des terrils devine du
co2 dans l'air etc
c'est ça en fait l'activité économique
et là j'ai toujours pas parler d'euros
proche famille dort où je vous ai montré
le dirham de flux alors les euros il
arrive et vous allez voir pourquoi là à
un moment il ya quelqu'un qui a dit dans
cette histoire la seule chose à laquelle
je vais m'intéresser c'est ce que je
paye aux hommes
le reste je m'en fous ça m'intéresse pas
quand les économistes classiques
théorise l'économie à deux siècles
c'est exactement ça qu'ils disent ils
disent l'économie c'est la gestion des
ressources rares
il ya deux siècles on est 500 millions
d'agriculteurs sur terre donc tout ce
qui est rare chez les hommes le reste
est infini et dur et je vous montrerai
dans pas longtemps une citation de jean
baptiste say c'est l'ancêtre du sucrier
beaucoup de nuisibles dans la famille et
vous verrez que il dit très exactement
ça
il dit eh bien le les ressources
naturelles on s'en fout complètement
parce qu'on considère qu'elles sont
limitées
effectivement il ya deux siècles c'est
une bonne approximation au premier ordre
500 millions d'agriculteurs sur terre
pourrait considérer que la nature est
infinie donc tout ce qui vous compte
tout ce que vous tous que comptent les
économistes à l'époque c'est les
ressources vraiment rare le seul goulets
d'étranglement c'est la quantité de gens
capables de travailler
alors aujourd'hui deux siècles après il
ya des gens qui raisonnent encore comme
ça je me rappelle très bien d'un bouquin
de christian blanc qui avait la
croissance ou le chaos c'est le même que
celui qui a voulu faire le grand paris
on savait l'université de paris saclay
et c'est peut-être pas plus de
commentaires que ça et dans son bouquin
christian ambiant explique que la
production agricole d'un champ est
strictement proportionnelles au nombre
d'agriculteurs que vous mettez dans le
champ rigolez pas c'est écrit c'est
écrit
enfin vous savez si un jour vous faites
venir dans cet amphi le sieur gaël
giraud il vous expliquera que dans les
modèles macroéconomiques utilisé par les
économistes vous avez un consommateur
représentatif avec un produit
représentatif c'est pas tellement plus
malins pas trop ce qu'on peut sortir
comme prédiction d'un truc pareil
donc vous avez ici le l'endroit où on
met les euros donc on va compter ce qui
vient des salaires et des rentes human
voilà c'est tout donc nos gisements de
pétrole tant que personne ne s'en est
servi il est gratuit et il devient
payant le jour où quelqu'un dit il est à
moi et à ce moment ce que vous allez
payer c'est par mère nature café le
gisement c'est la personne qui dit il
est à moi c'est ça que vous allez passer
cette personne là vous allez payer puis
vous allez payer des gens qui bossent
pour faire sortir le pétrole il est
évident que c'est un système qui ne
permet pas de voir venir la diminution
des stocks qui sont pourtant
indispensables à la pérennité du système
il est là le biais on ne voit pas venir
parce qu'à partir du moment où vous
dites les stocks sont infinies
évidemment deltastock nuls donc fait pas
comme le savant cosinus là vous emmerdez
pas baladé des + 0 partout dans nos
équations
c'est ça de côté et donc par
construction on a décidé que l'économie
ne s'occuperait pas de la diminution des
stocks et qu'elle ne les verrai pas
venir
il est évident qu'au début si on avait
voulu faire une comptabilité orthodoxe
une comptabilité actif passif comme on
fait dans une entreprise
eh bien vous auriez compter ça en plus
ça en moins et le jour où la valeur
marginale de la dernière voiture que
vous avez produite est inférieure à la
diminution marginal de valeur des stocks
que vous avez utilisé pour produire
votre dernière voiture vous vous arrêtez
de faire des voitures et vous vivez
happily ever after avec les voitures
existantes
bien évidemment de passer aujourd'hui à
ce système économique
un énorme défaut c'est que vous passez
d'un système qui autorise l'infini un
système qu'il autorise plus parce que
dans la théorie classique d'aujourd'hui
économique vous n'avez aucune règle qui
vous dit 20 quand le pib mondiale
atteindra 99999 milliards de dollars ça
s'arrête
tc comme le bug de l'an 2000 99,9 baisse
vous arrêtez vous avez pas ça dans la
théorie économique aujourd'hui rien ne
vous dit que le pib va s'arrêter de
croître quand il arrive à un niveau
donné rien un croissance foreurs ça si
on avait théorisée comme ça eh bien on
vous aurait dit à un moment le jeu
s'arrête
et c'était bien évidemment donc passé à
ce genre de système aujourd'hui
évidemment c'est désagréable
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que le
monde ya deux siècles et est
renouvelable c'est aussi la raison pour
laquelle on est passé on a quitté les
nerfs la physique pardon je vais pour
illustrer mon propos imaginer que je
prenne le volume d'air contenues dans
cette salle qui en ordre de grandeur est
pas très loin d'un cube de 10 mètres de
côté j'ai bien un ordre de grandeur ce
qui est deux fois sa pimpante
j'imagine que je fais souffle et se vend
à 80 km/heure ce qui commence à être un
vent un peu sympathique quand on vous
annonce à sur les crêtes en général vous
restez chez vous et que je le fais
passer dans une éolienne est bien la
quantité d'électricité c'est toujours un
milieu mv2 et bien la quantité
d'électricité que vous allez récupérer
en sortie d'éoliennes avec ce genre
d'opération c'est la même que l'énergie
que vous avez dans 3000 litres de
pétrole c'est pas beaucoup de 3000
litres et ce qui est sûr par contre
c'est que la facilité que vous avez
aujourd'hui à faire un trou dans le
désert saoudien pour sortir trois mille
litres de pétrole est
incommensurablement supérieur à la
facilité avec laquelle vous allez devoir
planté ce moulin à vent des temps
modernes pour en faire sortir de
l'électricité qui en plus fera avancer
le train quand tu auras du gant alors ne
rigolez pas quand je vous dis ça je vous
rappelle que la marine à voile c'était
exactement ça les marchandises étaient
livrés quand y avait du vent et c'est
comme ça que la société était organisée
et le grain été moulues quand y avait du
vent c'est comme ça que c'était organisé
et s'il n'y avait pas de vent et bien il
n'y avait pas de grain voulu poser un
petit problème
enfin là encore on pouvait faire des
stocks et si la marine arrivait pas à
s'emballer marin bourré du scorbut fin
sauf s'il avait pris des citrons et que
les citrons avait pas moisi mais sinon
il m'aurait du scorbut
donc vous avez un enfant vous attrapez
le corps buts en tout cas donc la raison
pour laquelle on n'est pas céder de
l'énergie du vent à l'énergie fossile
c'est tout simplement parce qu'elle est
considérablement
concentré et elle permet de disposer de
puissance considérablement plus
importante
et du coup ça permet de transformer
beaucoup plus vite tout ce qui nous
entoure et à partir du moment où on
donne une contrepartie économique à tout
ça ça nous permet de entre guillemets
faire de l'économie beaucoup plus
rapidement donc là je suis déjà en train
de vous dire en filigrane mais j'y
reviendrais plus tard
kuhn enak une économie qui repasserait
100% er en fait vous ne savez pas le
faire sans organiser une récession
massive
on peut le souhaiter il faut peut-être
le souhaitez mais à mon avis ça fera
partie des contreparties non négociable
mais je reviendrai plus tard si je
regarde micro économiquement là où on en
est aujourd'hui
vous prenez un kilowattheure sortie
d'une éolienne sans la fonction de stock
je dis bien sans la fonction de stock ça
coûte quelques centimes alors 6 à 8
ailleurs où il ya beaucoup de vent 4 peu
importe l'ordre de grandeur c'est ça
mais surtout si vous rajoutez la
fonction de stock
c'est alors si vous dites que vous
entendez avoir de l'électricité dans
cette pièce
y compris quand ya pas de vent à ce
moment vous devez stocker restituer et
là que vous utilisiez une step dont vous
avez quelques exemplaires la des
stations de pompage et barrages
réversible dont vous avez quelques
exemplaires dans les alpes en
construction à 9
c'est un truc qui vaut quelques milliers
d'euros du kilo watt installé que vous
utilisiez une batterie même celle de
tesla etc vous pouvez multiplier par
trois à six en face le kilowattheure de
pétrole coûte 0 3 centime sorti depuis
03 et à ce prix là vous avez déjà la
fonction de stock qu'à ce prix là vous
mettez votre truc dans un réservoir et
vous l'utilisez déjà quand vous avez
décidé que votre bagnole vous amener de
chez vous jusqu'à l'université
déjà ce que je suis en train de vous
dire c'est qu'il ya un facteur de prix
donc de gens mis au travail puisque je
vous ai dit juste avant que l'argent ne
paye que les hommes
en fait le prix de l'énergie ça n'est
rien d'autre que la quantité de gens
qu'il faut employer pour extraire de
l'environnement une énergie qui est
gratuite dans tous les cas de figure
dans tous les cas de figure donc la
quantité de gens qu'il faut mettre au
travail pour avoir une énergie
disponible à la demande
dans le premier cas de figure c'est 50 à
100 fois supérieur à ce que vous devez
avoir
dans le deuxième cas de figure
donc dans le premier cas de figure vous
n'avez pas une société industrielle qui
a dégagé le travail manuel
des chercheurs en physique qui peuvent
du coup chercher la physique watch reste
peu importe la sociologie et laurent que
whatever et faire du cinéma
alors que dans le premier cas de figure
tout le monde bosse pour extraire
l'énergie de l'environnement sous forme
de vente sous forme de photosynthèse et
donc j'ai pas le temps de faire autre
chose la fraise très forte productivité
du travail de la société moderne va
paradoxalement de pair avec le fait que
vous employez très très peu de gens dans
la filière énergétique
c'est ça le grand paradoxe donc plus
vous mettrez de gens dans la filière
énergétique - la société globalement
sera productive encore une fois on peut
désirer c'est pas le sujet mais en
contrepartie les deux vont ensemble
cette énergie abondante elle a
considérablement déformer la structure
de l'emploi
vous avez ici la structure de l'emploi
en france sur les deux derniers siècles
de siècle c'est une série longue qui
commence à être intéressante pour
raconter des choses envoyée il ya deux
siècles
l'essentiel de nos ancêtres sont
agriculteurs donc confère ce que j'ai
dis juste avant ils sont occupés à
extraire de l'environnement la seule
énergie qu'on sait à ce moment
domestique et de manière large
c'est-à-dire la photosynthèse et ils
font de l'alimentation qui est
l'essentiel de l'apport énergétique qui
concerne l'humanité
ils sont suffisamment productif ces
agriculteurs pour que chacun d'entre eux
soit capable de se nourrir lui même plus
une demi personne qui fait autre chose
c'est ça que ça veut dire d'avoir deux
tiers de la population qui travaille
dans les champs
cette population agricole
elle augmente jusqu'en 1850 alors à
l'époque la productivité du travail
agricole n'augmente pas beaucoup donc ce
qui se passe c'est que la population
elle suit en gros les surfaces
disponibles des surfaces agricoles
disponibles et les surfaces agricoles en
france ont augmenté jusqu'en 1850 le
minimum forestier donc le maximum de
déforestation pour faire des champs que
nous ayons eue en europe
c'était 1850 à l'époque la couverture
forestière de l'europe c'est 15%
aujourd'hui c'est remonté à 25 grâce
notamment aux tracteurs et aux engrais
en paradoxes
et donc la population agricole augmente
et puis arrive de plus en plus de
machines et d'énergie et à ce moment ces
machines et cette énergie vont permettre
de doter les agriculteurs d'une quantité
croissante d'instruments de productivité
collier de trait des charrues amélioré
et ses avants avant bien avant les
tracteurs et donc à ce moment vous
améliorer un peu la productivité
agricole et à ce moment vous avez la
possibilité à surface donnée de diminuer
la quantité de gens qui travaillent dans
les champs
et puis ils vont faire autre chose grâce
à l'énergie aussi on valoir dans pas
longtemps après la guerre alors là on
met directement les machines dans les
champs les tracteurs et on met au
travail ailleurs des machines
surpuissantes qui vont s'appeler d usine
de production d'engrais grâce aux
énergies fossiles
je ne sais pas si vous le savez mais les
engrais azotés qu'on utilise aujourd'hui
dans les champs et qui remplacent les
quatre bestiaux diverses et variées
qu'on utilisait avant le fumier le
lisier les blues et bien sont faits avec
du gaz qui a beau être naturel c'est
quand même une énergie fossile le début
de la fabrication des engrais c'est la
fabrication de l'ammoniac et pour faire
de l'ammoniac vous prenez du méthane ch4
ou de casser en deux vous virez le
carbone qu'il part dans l'ère du reste
pour faire du co2 vous récupérez
l'hydrogène de l'autre côté donc faire
de l'hydrogène aujourd'hui on s'est très
très bien faire pour faire des engrais
et ça vaut crachotant de co2 vous voulez
donc que la civilisation hydrogène ça
soit propre
ça dépend comment vous faites
l'hydrogène donc vous prenez l'hydrogène
vous l'associez à l'azoté de l'air ça
vous fait de l'ammoniac et à partir de
là vous faites des ammonitrates qui sont
les fameuses engrais azotés qu'on
utilise le plus fréquemment
donc on met les en grève et la
productivité des terres céréalières en
france entre 1945 et la fin du xxème
siècle a été multiplié par six à huit
six à huit c'est grâce à ça que vous
mangez de la viande tous les jours
donc si vous mangez de la viande tous
les jours c'est à cause du pétrole et du
gaz
sinon ça marche pas
et par ailleurs à cause de la puissance
unitaire d'un tracteur que je vous
montrerai dans pas longtemps et bien
j'ai plus besoin des paysans dans les
champs exit les paysans dehors à oust et
j'en fais les chercheurs alors pas tout
de suite quand même il va y avoir une
étape intermédiaire l'approvisionnement
croissants en énergie permettant de
diffuser de manière croissante le parc
de machines va aussi permettre
d'augmenter une autre population qui est
la population des ouvriers ans qu'est ce
que c'est qu'un ouvrier c'est quelqu'un
qui pilote une machine se sent un
ouvrier totalement ou partiellement
vous vous rappelez des temps modernes 1
et de chaplin sur sa chaîne de montage
et bien l'ouvrier n'est rien d'autre
qu'une forme d'esclaves des temps
modernes au service de sa machine
aujourd'hui un ouvrier dans une usine il
est au service d'une machine parce que
sans la machine il est au chômage
sans le sang la cabine de peinture
l'ouvrier pas appréciera rien sans la
chaîne de montage de la voiture
l'ouvrier de l'automobile ne sert à rien
et sans lui la chaîne de montage de
l'électronique l'ouvrier l'électronique
y sert à rien encore donc l'ouvrier
aujourd'hui est un auxiliaire de la
machine c'est pas désagréable avec les
ouvriers c'est une réalité physique
d'accord et l'ouvrier du btp est un
auxiliaire du marteau piqueur voilà donc
l'ouvrier est un auxiliaire de la
machine à cette époque là la
productivité alors pardon la puissance
unitaire par machines augmente moins
vite
suivez bien parce que c'est un peu
subtile la puissance unitaire par
machines augmente moins vite que
l'approvisionnement énergétique globale
donc le nombre de machines augmente la
puissance par machines augmente mais le
nombre de machines augmente aussi
donc le nombre d'emplois dans
l'industrie augmentent à partir des
chocs pétroliers
il se passe linverse et vous allez voir
un peu plus tard les chocs pétroliers
c'est une rupture de dérivés sur
l'approvisionnement énergétique mondial
et donc à ce moment là la productivité
ou la puissance unitaire des machines
continue d'augmenter et à ce moment elle
va se mettre à augmenter plus vite que
l'approvisionnement énergétique mondial
à ce moment là le nombre de machines en
service pour un même approvisionnements
énergétiques baisse et le nombre
d'emplois dans l'industrie baisse ça
veut pas dire que la production
industrielle baisse soit dit en passant
la production industrielle en europe
elle a atteint son maximum en 2007 au
double de ce qu'elle était à 74
donc la délocalisation de l'industrie
c'est plus vite dit que fait mais par
contre ce qui est sûr c'est que la
puissance par machine elle encore une
fois elle va se mettre à augmenter plus
vite que l'approvisionnement énergétique
globale et donc le nombre d'emplois dans
l'industrie baisse puisque je le redis
un emploi dans l'industrie c'est un
emploi au service de la machine
c'est un emploi au service de la machine
et puis pardon et puis dans cette
affaire-là vous voyez également
apparaître les emplois de service alors
au début les emplois de service il
augmente au même rythme que les emplois
dans l'industrie parce que quand vous
fabriquez une casserole dans ma foi il
faut le vendre c'est dans les services
il faut éventuellement la finance et
c'est dans les services faut la réparer
c'est dans les services etc
et puis il faut faire des courbettes au
maître de maison qui a fait fortune dans
les casseroles au début du 19e siècle
une bonne partie des emplois de service
c'est des emplois de maison c'est les
gens qui travaillent chez les bourgeois
après le choc pétrolier la production
industrielle globale continue
d'augmenter
donc les services peuvent augmenter puis
en fait y en a une partie qui servent à
mutualiser le la production industrielle
on va dire qu'ils augmentent moins vite
mais vous voyez apparaître partout dans
tous les pays occidentaux à la même
époque une nouvelle catégorie d'actifs
qui s'appelle les chômeurs vous êtes
suffisamment vieux un certain nombre de
gens dans cette salle pour vous en
rappeler au moment des chocs pétroliers
juste avant les [ __ ] chômage c'était
2,5 ou 3 % de la population active et
overnight en deux ans est passé à dix
quand on n'est jamais vraiment
redescendu soit dit en passant c'est
exactement pareil pour l'endettement
mais pour des raisons différentes
donc là vous avez de big picture de ce
qui se passe sur la déformation de la
structure des emplois quand vous
commencez à mettre de plus en plus
d'énergie c'est à dire de plus en plus
de machines dans un pays
tous les pays qui se sont mis à avoir
accès à l'énergie ont tous suivi la même
évolution
je le vire les gens deschamps je leur
mets des machines outil entre les mains
j'augmente l'industrie et j'augmente les
services et comme c'est plus facile
d'avoir des industries parce que tous
les gens doivent habiter au même endroit
et des services parce que tous les gens
doivent échanger au même endroit dans
les villes ben j'ai mis tout le monde
dans les villes contrairement à une idée
souvent répandue la civilisation urbaine
est une civilisation énergivore
pas à cause du fonctionnement
intrinsèque de la ville à cause de la
structure de l'emploi qui va avec
donc dans un monde où l'énergie se
raréfie les villes deviendront de moins
en moins économiquement soutenable et
toujours pour des raisons physiques
ça commencera par les banlieues ça doit
notamment sa doit normalement vous
rappelez un petit quelque chose il ya
l'actualité en ce moment c'est normal ce
qui est en train de se passer et c'est
en train de se passer dans tous les pays
d'europe en même temps c'est en train de
se passer en grande-bretagne
c'est en train de se passer en allemagne
c'est en train de se passer en italie
c'est en train de se passer en espagne
vous regarderez la structure spatiale
des gens qui commencent à être sortie du
jeu ça se passe toujours au même endroit
et il ya une raison physique à ça il ya
une raison physique et voilà une petite
série statistique vous avez compris que
j'avais bien les séries pour vous
montrer que c'est par exemple le cas sur
l'agriculture alors j'aurais pu vous
montrer également des régressions avec
par des urbains versus consommation
énergétique par personne je n'ai pas eu
le temps en train de retrouver le
graphique en question mais il existe là
vous en avait un qui vous donnent la
part de l'emploi dans l'agriculture dans
tous les pays du monde donc ça c'est une
photo à ce que je vous ai montré avancé
le film en france ça c'est une photo
chaque point rouge représente un pays
dans le monde et pour ce pays dans le
monde
j'ai mis sur un axe la part de l'emploi
dans l'agriculture et sur l'autre axe
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne dans le pays en question
on va vous voyez que une très bonne
approximation de cette série c1 sur x ou
quelque chose qui y ressemble donc dit
autrement dis moi combien il ya de
machines qui bosse dans le pays je te
dirai de combien de paysans j'ai encore
besoin pour repérer les machines dans
les champs c'est à peu près ça que ça
dit et je le répète tout ça est gratuit
à cause de lui donc je vais revenir à ma
théorie économique
donc voici le sieur jean baptiste say il
n'a pas dit que des bêtises mais enfin
il a à cette époque-là incarner ce
qu'était la pensée économique globale
alors il faut que je retrouve les
citations de ricardo et d'autre mais il
a dit et ça c'est texto 1
mot-à-mot dans son traité d'économie
politique les ressources naturelles
sortie épuisable axiome une ressource
naturelle senti épuisable bombe à une
fois que vous avez postulé que les
ressources naturelles étaient
inépuisables et quand même pas vous
emmerder avec des gens qui vous disent
que ce n'est pas le cas c'est la raison
pour laquelle quand on est un économiste
sérieux on n'écoute pas les gens
farfelues qui vous disent que la terre
est finie peut-être que si on s'y prend
bien le diamètre de la terre peut passer
de 13 mille kilomètres à 18000 négocier
que les syndicats étaient arrivés
voilà donc il a dit notre ami
les ressources sont illimitées j'ai pas
la peine que je m'emmerde avec et du
coup comme elles sont illimitées je ne
m'en occuperai pas dans mes équation
donc maintenant les superbes équation
série convergentes divergentes machin
aux dérivées partielles etc
en fait sont toutes basées sur un
postulat totalement faux qui est que ce
que nous a donnée mère-nature en 14
milliards d'années
depuis le big bang savons rien voilà
c'est la raison pour laquelle on a un
peu de mal à faire de l'économie
prédictive en fait c'est pas sorcier
c'est normal je vous le dit autrement
les codes invite vous avez apprise à
l'école et je suppose on apprend
toujours à l'école c'est que le système
productif à deux facteurs de production
les gens qui bossent donc s'il n'y a pas
assez de gens qui bossent ont leur botte
le cul le matin on en voit
les inspecteurs de pôle emploi vérifier
qu'ils cherchent bien un boulot etc
on les paye moins du capital et donc si
les banquiers font n'importe quoi avec
leur pognon leur botte le cul en leur
menace est coupée en deux et c est une
fois vous avez ces deux facteurs de
production or le supermarché rempli un
beau non voilà ça c'est la vision
conventionnelle du système économique
alors dans cette vision conventionnel là
je suis désolé d'employer des gros mots
enfin pour ceux d'entre vous sont pas
encore totalement fatigué de ce que je
raconte dans cette affaire là à ce
moment vous vous rendez compte que le
pib il est endogène du capital et du
travail facteurs sur lesquels vous
n'allez pas posé de limites à priori par
contre il est exogène de l'énergie
puisque l'énergie est une ressource
naturelle et exogènes de l'énergie donc
le pib peut croître indéfiniment et à ce
moment ça appelle une énergie qui
croient indéfiniment donc l'économiste
il dit ben voilà d'abord j'ai du capital
et du travail
ensuite j'ai du pib comme j'ai du pib
qui vient de mars je consomme de
l'énergie mettre d'accord et donc mon
énergie va être appelé à mesure d'un pib
qui croient sais pas pourquoi il croit
mais y croit et en fait dans la quasi
totalité des modèles qui s'occupe y
compris des ressources finies de la
planète c'est là que ça devient très
drôle le pib est exogène ne rigolait pas
et je note un jeune homme aurait
personne j'en connais dont un qui est
utilisé ici donc non dans la quasi
totalité d'un imac lim qui est utilisée
aussi raide pib et exogènes n'a pas de
sens ça n'a aucun sens mais c'est quand
même comme ça qu'on fonctionne en fait
bien évidemment c'est dans l'autre sens
que ça marche
d'abord j'ai des ressources donc je suis
capable de les transformer donc je suis
capable de leur donner une contrepartie
économique l'économie ne fait que
comptait des flux donc de la physique
fait que ça l'économie
dans le système conventionnel voilà j'y
reviens et c'est ça c'est gratuit dans
le système conventionnel
tout est gratuit y compris le pétrole
alors voilà du pétrole ces jolis seins
enfin c'est du pétrolier 50 millions
d'années je précise quand même
qu'est ce que c'est que le pétrole ya 50
millions d'années c'est des
micro-organismes marins éventuellement
lacustre mais en général marc alors
comme c'est des micro organismes
les biologistes qui j'ai confiance me
disent il ya du carbone parce que la vie
sur terre c'est la chaîne du carbone
donc il a dû carbone
ces micro organismes ne sont pas plus
éternel que vous et moi même un peu
moins éternel que vous et moi donc de
temps en temps il meurt alors
l'essentiel de ces micro-organismes
quand il mord ils sont la partie
biologique elle est dégradée très
rapidement et ont circulé dans les
cycles biogéochimiques mais enfin il y
en a quand même une petite partie qui va
tomber au fond des océans et qui va être
mélangés au fond des océans avec des
sédiments en formation qui vont venir
des coquilles de ces mêmes
micro-organismes marins plus des
poussières a mené par le vent plus des
poussières et des allusions a mené par
les rivières dans tout ça vous fait un
petit truc sympa vous enfouissez ça avec
la tectonique des plaques de temps en
temps sous terre vous laissez cuire de
manière anaérobie pendant quelques
dizaines de millions d'années et arrive
un gisement de pétrole d'un gisement de
pétrole et bien si vous allez faire un
trou au bon endroit évidemment le
pétrole sort tout ça est gratuit le
pétrole est aussi gratuite le vent ce
qui coûte dans les deux cas de figure
c'est le travail humain pour aller le
chercher et le fait de payer la personne
qui vous dit tu me payes
sinon je te laisse pas accéder à mon
pétrole où soit dit en passant tu me
passes sur le corps ce qui est une autre
version qu'on a utilisées de temps en
temps mais ce qui vous coûte aussi de
l'argent donc ce que vous allez payer
c'est pas la ressource
le pétrole est aussi gratuit que le vent
donc quand vous entendez dans un
discours quelconque on aurait tort de
passer arrière du vent et du soleil
parce que c'est gratuit
mais oui on aurait tort de ne pas se
servir du pétrole c'est tout aussi
gratuit pas de différence il n'y a pas
de différence
aucune ressource les payantes aucune
dans tous les cas de figure vous allez
payer des salaires et des rentes aux
gens qui en sont les dépositaires du
moment et ceux qui vont travailler pour
extraire l'énergie en pratique
c'est la seule chose que vous allez
payer à chaque fois voilà donc dans le
système économique classique ça ça ne
vaut rien alors c'est quand même un peu
emmerdant parce que si vous avez ça vous
n'avez pas le reste si je vous mets au
milieu du vide intersidéral demain matin
d'accord fin des accélérateurs linéaires
du laboratoire de glaciologie tous à
jouer au milieu du vide intersidéral et
vous dis publiée dans nature très chers
messieurs nous aller voir un peu de mal
quand même
donc les ressources qui sont absolument
indispensables à ce qu'on exerce notre
activité je le redis sont à coût zéro
alors je me suis amusé à faire un petit
calcul qui vaut ce qui vaut pour vous
montrer que en fait évidemment la
dotation aux amortissements je peux la
beta plus l'infini aucun problème avec
ça vous avez ici la station spatiale
internationale je sais pas si certains
d'entre vous ont entendu parler de cette
bestiole donc c'est un joujou un peu
cher que on s'est amusé à envoyer dans
l'espace pour savoir si c'était
sympathique de voir le paysage vu dans
la station spatiale internationale vos
ordres de grandeurs 100 milliards de
dollars et elle offre pour six habitants
un tout petit embryon de planète terre
je dis bien à tout petit embryon
alors pour 100 milliards de dollars qu
est-ce que vous avez vous avez une
pression atmosphérique à 1000
hectopascals d'accord vous êtes protégé
de la pression ambiante à 50 ou 100 ou
200 ch et plus exactement à quelle
altitude et les quelques centaines
kilomètres du sol vous avez une
température ambiante qui est un peu
au-dessus du point triple de l'eau parce
que sinon la température ambiante là bas
est plutôt du côté de quelques kelvink
pas très chaud vous avez le droit de
boire vos urines recyclé dont vous avez
un début de cycle de l'eau puis point
quoi c'est tout à ce prix là dans 15
milliards de dollars par personne
vous avez toujours par le moins deux
mètres carrés pour faire pousser une
carotte
vous n'avez pas le moindre code
génétique de coccinelles rien 0 15
milliards de dollars
vous n'avez pas le moins deux gisements
de cuivre donc pour 15 milliards de
dollars vous avez vraiment une toute
petite partie des services que la terre
nous offrent gratuitement
je le répète une atmosphère au niveau du
sol c'est gratos aussi un rien payé pour
ça
alors maintenant ce capital vous avez
compris avec le petit diagramme que j'ai
fait tout à l'heure que on est en train
de le manger ce capital 1 on est en
train d'en consommer chaque année une
fraction croissante
alors question qu'est-ce que je compte
je dis voilà donc la planète terre c'est
au moins 15 milliards de dollars par
personne alors à quelle vitesse est ce
que je la consomme ma planète terre je
prendre quelques exemples
je prends un premier exemple c'est les
poissons en bout de chaîne alimentaire
des poissons nobles ce qu'on pêche dans
l'océan et la densité approximative
évidemment reconstitué à partir des
prélèvements des stocks de poissons que
nous avions dans l'atlantique nord il ya
un siècle et aujourd'hui vous voyez que
ça a été divisé par un facteur 10 alors
si vous prenez la racine centièmes sur
un siècle d'une division par dix vous
êtes dans un ordre de grandeur qui est
une diminution annuelle de l'ordre du
pur sang un peu au dessus mais c'est de
l'ordre du pur sang je prends maintenant
mes stocks d'hydrocarbures
vous avez ici une courbe qui vous décrit
sommairement j'y reviendrai l'extraction
mondiale de ce qu'on appelle des
hydrocarbures liquides dans lequel on
agrège le vrai pétrole y compris le
pétrole de schiste
ce qui vient des bitumes au canada en
coupe en pleine forêt ce qui vient des
du gaz et condensats de gaz etc et
aujourd'hui on est là donc en gros on en
a sorti entre le tiers et la moitié
pareil si vous avez divisé par deux en
l'espace d'un siècle
ben vous voyez vous n'êtes pas dans
l'ordre du pur sang vous êtes dans une
fraction 2% vous êtes au dessus du pour
mille en termes de diminution annuelle
je pourrais continuer il ya un certain
nombre d'autres stocks pour lesquels le
facteur diviseur a été de quelques
unités
on a divisé par quelques unités 3 4 2 et
demi peu importe les forêts primaires
dont le temps de reconstitution est un
peu long - l'ont cependant que pour les
sols cultivables - l'ont encore que pour
les minerais de toute nature que nous
avons utilisés et puis on est en train
de déstabiliser un système climatique
dont le temps caractéristiques de retour
à l'équilibré se comptent en dizaines de
milliers d'années
donc si je met tout ça bout tabou je me
dis bah voilà c'est pas complètement
illégitime de pratiquer un amortissement
sur le capital naturel qui soit au moins
de leur dû pour mille et mon capital
naturel comme je le disais tout à
l'heure il vaut au moins 15 milliards de
dollars par personne
j'ai très con enfin dans ma longue vie
d'ingénieurs j'ai rarement vu des règles
de trois foncièrement validé par des
modélisations beaucoup plus sophistiqué
enfin quand la règle de trois est pas
trop mal posé évidemment donc je
pratique un amortissement de l'ordre du
pur mille donc j'ai amorti à hauteur de
15 millions de dollars par personne
et voilà la censure s'applique
c'est un scandale
c'est bon donc
donc j'ai 15 millions de dollars par an
d'amortissement par personne d'accord en
face de ça la production cherche ce que
je crée ses 15000 dollars par personne
au sens du pib c'est mon plus des
voitures donc aujourd'hui si je
réintègre les amortissements du capital
naturel dans l'activité que je suis en
train d'opérer sur la planète
et bien je peux soutenir par exemple que
je suis en train de pratiquer une vente
à perte dans laquelle mes charges me
coûte chaque année 1000 fois plus cher
que mes produits
voilà donc là je suis en train de vous
dire que de rendre l'environnement
compatible avec l'économique dans les
objectifs de développement durable c'est
à dire chaque année je vais augmenter un
peu mes flux là qui vont de la gauche
vers la droite dans le diagramme que je
vous ai montré tout en réglant tous les
problèmes d'environnement qui se
présentent
j'ai quand même quelques doutes sur
l'état de salubrité mentale des gens qui
ont pondu ça il y quelques doutes enfin
en fait j'ai aucun de doute sur ce
qu'ils avaient envie d'entendre les gens
qui était de l'autre côté c'est plutôt
ça le sujet donc le donc 7,7
qu'est ce que je veux dire cette
transformation elle est aujourd'hui
massive et pas du tout compatible avec
la préservation de l'environnement
alors je vais revenir un peu à ma
question d'énergie pour vous montrer où
ça peut aller à plus court terme dans le
paysage européen
je vous ai montré tout à l'heure la
différence de densité énergétique entre
une paire de jambes et un lit de pétrole
pour être un peu simple alors cette
différence là elle a permis de mettre en
oeuvre des machines qui ont elles mêmes
des écarts de puissance extrêmement
important avec nos bras et aux jambes
nos bras et logeant avec le petit calcul
que je voulais monter tout à l'heure ça
se balade entre 10 et 100 watts alors
monsieur pantani quand il montait le col
de chez pourquoi du galibier lui il
était plutôt un kilowatt mais enfin vous
n'êtes pas tous capables de faire ça il
ya une vidéo qui tourne sur internet où
vous avez l'actuel champion du monde de
cyclisme sur piste qui pédalent
suffisamment pour faire griller pour
faire oui grille un toast donc
fonctionner un toaster 700 watts
pendant une minute et demie le type à la
fin d'abord il ad il a des bras gros
comme vos cuisses et des cuisses groupe
comme jeu pourquoi mon entorse et au
bout d'une minute et demie il est au
bord de l'apoplexie il est obligé de se
coucher une minute et demie 700 watts 1
alors vous prenez le premier tracteur
venu le premier tracteur venu fait
quelques dizaines de kilowatts
c'est à dire que il est capable de
remplacer quelques centaines de
personnes dans les champs où quelques
dizaines d'animaux puisque en gros vous
avez un facteur 10 entre un animal de
trait et un homme vous prenez un
tractopelle enfin un engin de chantier
cet engin de chantier et capable de
contribuer à vous ériger avec ses petits
copains les cimenteries les camions etc
le bâtiment qui est au dessus de nos
têtes là on a un an alors qu'il a fallu
un siècle pour faire notre dame qui est
du même ordre en termes de taille alors
si je prend un tour à la défense c'est
vraiment du même ordre et donc dans un
cas c'est un an dans le cas c'est un
siècle la différence entre les deux
s'appelle le pétrole et le gaz et le
charbon et accessoirement le reste il
n'y a pas d'autres différences je crois
que les architectes égyptiens étaient
tout aussi géniaux que les architectes
modernes
quand on regarde les pyramides donc ya
pas de différence y en a qu'une qui
s'appelle l'énergie et donc ce que je
suis en train de vous montrer là vous
prenez un camion le camion il [ __ ]
comme quelques milliers de fois les
jambes du conducteur
c'est grâce à ça que vous mangez tous
les jours à votre faim parce que les
camions approvisionne les villans
nourriture tous les jours si demain
matin je supprime le pétrole en france
dans ce pays tout nucléaire vous allez
mourir de faim dans notre pays tout
nucléaire
parce que bien évidemment aujourd'hui
les villes sont totalement cas incapable
de fonctionner en autarcie alimentaire
l'hinterland alimentaire d'une ville
aujourd'hui c'est des milliers ou des
dizaines de milliers de kilomètres rayon
d'approvisionnement
même pour les locavores il reste le café
le chocolat bref un avion il [ __ ]
qu'en mai millions de fois les jambes du
pilote c'est pour ça que le pilote est
mieux payé avec le conducteur de camion
et un laminoir
il martèle comme toute l'ile-de-france
que j'aurais mise au travail avec un
marteau dans les mains sauf que cette
bestiole là est pilotée par une personne
il ya un ouvrier dans la cabine de
laminoirs peux vous dire j'ai visité une
personne donc je le redis l'énergie ça a
été la possibilité de mettre à notre
service des exosquelettes surpuissant
donc j'ai mis tout à l'heure en blague
que nietzsche voulait des surhommes et
que le pétrole l'a fait pour de vrai
mais c'est pas une blague
nous sommes tous devenus superman est
super woman pour devaux supergirl
whatever pour de vrai sauf que au lieu
que ce soit directement nos bras et aux
jambes dans un vrai exosquelette en fait
la prolongation exauce que l'éthique de
nos bras et aux jambes s'appelle des
voitures des camions votre frigo et
laminoirs voilà ça nous ressemble pas
c'est un peu compliqué d'avoir
l'anthropomorphisme eca laminoir quand
même en général on sent une tendresse
pour le laminoir un peu plus minces que
celles qu'on a pour un dauphin mais il
n'empêche c'est vraiment une
prolongation exauce que l'éthique de
notre organisme
c'est encore une fois c'est un autre
nous mêmes que nous avons mis à notre
service or cet autre nous mêmes on lui
donne à manger de l'énergie que voici
vous avez ici une courbe qui vous donne
l'approvisionnement énergétique par
personne sur un siècle et demi avec une
petite inconnue sur le bois parce que le
bois il ya des statistiques qui sont
compliqués à faire sur un siècle et demi
c'est une moyenne mondiale
c'est l'approvisionnement énergétique en
moyenne dans le monde par personne c'est
gratuit en kilowattheures c'est que vous
avez le droit de graduer toute énergie
en kilowattheures y compris le gaz le
charbon
il n'y a pas que l'électricité qu'on
mesure en kilowattheures d'un
kilowattheure de pétrole ces 10
centilitres donc vous avez le droit de
mesurer toute énergie en kilowattheures
ce que vous voyez sur ce graphique c'est
que à part le bois qui par personne a
baissé toutes les autres énergies sont
venus ce empilées les unes sur les
autres
tout donc il n'y a pas eu à l'échelle
mondiale de cannibalisme macroscopique
entre énergie à chaque fois qu'on en a
trouvé une nouvelle on y vient par ici
toi et crack
on leur a ajouté sur les précédentes
la raison pour laquelle le charbon n'a
jamais diminué dans le monde ni en
absolu ni même par personne c'est que
aujourd'hui le charbon est de loin le
premier mode de production électrique
dans le monde 40% de l'électricité
mondiale est faite au charbon et si je
vous dis je vous demande quelle est
l'énergie qui a le plus contribué à
l'accroissement de la production
électrique sur les dix dernières années
je suis sûr qu'il y aura dans la salle
qui vont dire c'est l'éolien et le
solaire mois une réponse c'est le
charbon
sur les dix dernières années sur l'année
dernière peut-être pas mais sur les dix
dernières années c'est certain le
pétrole est venue se rajouter par dessus
le charbon parce que le pétrole si
injuste pas la même chose
le pétrole il sert à se déplacer et à
déplacer des choses il y en a un tout
petit peu qui va dans les centrales
électriques pas beaucoup un petit peu
qui va dans le chauffage pas beaucoup
plus de la moitié du pétrole qu'on
extrait sur terre alimentent le système
mondial de transport puisque 98 % de
ceux qui roulent vol ou naviguer utilise
du pétrole alors 100 % de ce qui vole
nonobstant
l'avion solaire de monsieur picard 100 %
de ceux qui naviguent nonobstant
quelques bateaux à voile qui font la
transat est par contre pas tout à fait
un peu plus de 90% de ce qui roule parce
que maintenant vous commencez à avoir
des agrocarburants mais qui sont en fait
eux-mêmes inclusive d'énergies fossiles
qui ont été nécessaires pour cultiver
les végétaux et les distiller parfois le
gaz est venue se rajouter par le pays
bas etc
et puis alors récemment vous voyez il ya
un truc là zigouigouis qui excite tout
le monde sait les nouvelles énergies
renouvelables et donc ce que vous avez
en rose la celac c'est le
la moyenne par personne dans le monde de
l'ensemble des nouvelles énergies
renouvelables c'est à dire l'éolien le
solaire la géothermie l'eau biogaz le
houlomoteurs le marais botteur
l'hydrolien enfin bon tout les tous les
machins dans les pages de journaux sont
remplis en ce moment et alors évidemment
tout le monde est en train de vous dire
dormez tranquilles je prends ça là ça va
remplacer ça ça ça et même ça parce que
ckac à berck en l'espace de 35 ans alors
moi je veux bien
c'est physiquement possible physiquement
c'est possible arnaud costes sur la côte
sur le prix du bifteck
ou plus exactement la quantité que vous
allez pouvoir en manger la quantité de
kilomètres que vous allez pouvoir faire
la quantité de mètres carrés que vous
allez pouvoir occuper et le niveau de
votre retraite quelques doutes quand
j'ai une bonne nouvelle pour vous de
toute façon votre retraite va baisser
mais ça j'y viendrai après pour des
raisons énergétiques notamment
voilà mais ce que je tiens à vous dire à
ce moment en ce moment c'est que dans le
discours médiatique alors je suis désolé
s'il ya quelques journalistes dans la
salle mais un il ya un million c'est
bien le problème
une catastrophe c'est une fillette qui a
été violée un million de personnes 1 200
mille personnes qui sont mortes dans un
tsunami
un million de personnes qui meurent
parents du charbon etc tout ça c'est une
catastrophe
c'est un égal 1 donc et c'est très
rigolo
j'ai déjà vu des présentateur de journal
après un sujet faisait le sujet c'est
l'espèce de micro reportages là qui suit
en général ce qu'on appelle un lancement
par le présentateur du journal ou un
commentaire en plateau quand vous êtes
invité à une émission de télévision donc
le sujet c'est la partie reportage qui
s'intercale et bien dans un sujet j'ai
déjà vu sur certains sujets pardon de la
répétition
le commentateur du reportage d'hier il y
en a pour des centaines de millions de
dégâts et juste après la personne qui
reprend le sujet à dire alors vous voyez
il va y en avoir pour des milliers
d'euros pas confondu des milliers les
centaines de millions aucun problème à
dire ça
donc c'est très très difficile en se
cantonnant à la partie médiatique du
débat de sortir de ce genre de
discussion qui n'est qu'une discussion
de chiffres l'énergie ça n'est qu'une
discussion de chiffres donc vous n'avez
rien fait d'autre que de sortir quelques
slogans
tant que vous n'avez pas parlé chiffres
n'aient rien fait d'autre
holy slogan c'est ce qui nous fait
avancer temps en temps je dis pas qu'il
faut pas en faire mais vous avez intérêt
à vérifier qu'ils sont raccord avec les
chiffres
aujourd'hui ce qui fournit 80 % de la
nourriture des machines dans le monde
tels carbone c'est-à-dire pétrole gaz
charbon s'est également vu en europe
c'est également vrai en europe on n'est
pas différent du reste du monde
80% de l'énergie en europe des fossiles
il ya quelques exceptions notables dont
la france mais globalement c'est 80%
alors vous voyez sur ce graphique que le
niveau d'approvisionnement énergétique
auquel on en est arrivé aujourd'hui
c'est vingt mille kilowatts heure par
personne et par an en termes
d'approvisionnement énergétique
extracorporelle ce que je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure c'est qu'un homme pouvait
fournir au maximum 100 kilowatts heure
d'énergie par an avec son énergie intra
corporelle son alimentation
donc je vous prends une règle comme ça
qui vaut ce qu'elle vaut et qui vous dit
j'aurais pu la mettre à 150 à 250 ou
as400 peu importe vous avez deux ordres
de grandeur de différence entre la
puissance des carcasses humaine sur
terre des sept milliards d'humains enfin
cet ennemi et la puissance des machines
installées sur terre fonctionne en h24
la puissance moyenne du parc de machines
en fonctionnement sur terre h 24 c'est
200 x 500 en occident vraisemblablement
la puissance de nos propres aux
organismes dans le même pays c'est ça
l'énergie donc c'est ce qui a fait tout
le monde qui vous entoure
c'est une autre manière de dire que dans
les objectifs du développement durable
si nous ne savons pas atterri en douceur
sur la question énergétique c'est pas la
peine de vous occuper du reste ça
marchera pas ça ne marchera pas
dans les approches dites le sg dans
lesquels on met sur un même pied
d'égalité au lait noir les homosexuels
les unijambistes et l'énergie c'est
quelque chose qui est méthodologiquement
totalement impropres parce que je leur
dise si on fait n'importe quoi enfin si
on ne sait pas atterrir en douceur sur
l'énergie tout ce qu'on peut avoir comme
ambition sympathique sur le reste ça
marchera pas alors il faut que je vous
ai dit tout ça je vais revenir à pour
moi la bonne manière de théoriser
l'énergie l'économie et vous allez voir
que je vais mettre le facteur limitant
au premier ordre ailleurs que dans les
hommes donc vous avez toujours le
supermarché qui remplit et moi je dis
pour que le supermarché soit remplie il
faut que vous ayez le tableau de
mendeleïev en entrée dire autrement les
atomes constitutifs de tout ce que vous
trouvez au supermarché si vous n'avez
pas les ressources et les atomes dedans
qui vous permettent de les faire ces
produits vous n'avez pas de produits je
le redis vous mettez un forever au
milieu du vide intersidéral sans
approvisionnement en sable et en
carbonate de calcium je pense que vous
n'avez pas de verre donc vous avez
vraiment besoin des ressources à
transformer pour faire les produits et
puis vous avez besoin de la capacité de
transformation c'est à dire du travail
et ce travail avec l'ordre de grandeur
que je viens de vous exposer
il est fourni pour un parent nos pauvres
carcasse et pour 200 par le parc de
machines mondialement jean sa nourriture
qui lui est propre qui s'appelle
l'énergie
alors dans cette manière de voir
l'économie
le capital c'est une boucle interne du
système
je le redis les éléments de capital sont
fait exactement de la même façon
ou bien assez des ressources naturelles
encore à l'état brut à la terre les
temps anciens
ou bien c'est des ressources qui ont été
transformés tels cet immeuble est ce que
je dis c'est que l'économie elle est là
j'achète la théorie anciennes
en fait elle est limitée par le premier
de ces facteurs limitant donc il ya deux
siècles on a dit le premier des facteurs
limitants ne peut être que le capital
humain où le nombre de travailleurs et
moi je vous dis non
avec la machine aujourd'hui qui bosse à
notre place le facteur limitant ça peut
très bien être l'énergie pour les
machines et à ce moment ça me produit le
même effet donc si je manque d'énergie
ou si je provoque délibérément une
contraction rapide de
l'approvisionnement énergétique ça ne
change rien et bien le résultat c'est
que le supermarché est moins bien rempli
et la manière dont je vais compter ça
avec mon indicateur orthodoxe sais que
j'aurai moins de pib
donc là je suis déjà en train de vous
dire que l'accord de pareilles est
récessif j'ai déjà en train de vous dire
que l'accord de paris récessif parce que
80 % d'énergies fossiles dans
l'approvisionnement mondial
vous ne remplacerez pas en 35 ans par
des énergies renouvelables et du
nucléaire
never ever donc vous allez contracter
fortement si on tient bon on va pas le
tenir rassurez-vous si on le tient on va
contracter fortement l'approvisionnement
énergétique tout court donc vous avez
contracté rapidement la production
économique tout court c'est aussi bête
que ça
et c'est pour ça que c'est inaudible et
c'est pour ça que comme le dit mon ami
brice lalonde ça fait 23 coop qu'on n'a
toujours pas réussi à se mettre d'accord
et je pense qu'on ne se mettra jamais
d'accord ou plus exactement quand on
sera mis d'accord au kop sait qu'on sera
mis d'accord partout ailleurs ça viendra
en bout de processus et sûrement pas au
début même motif même punition si vous
manquez de ressources et bien vous allez
manquer de produits dans le supermarché
alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut avoir en
manque de ressources vous pouvez très
bien avoir par exemple localement on
commence à avoir ce problème dans les
matériaux de construction
un manque de matériaux de construction
pardon pour la répétition dont pouvait
manquer de carrière ont manqué de sable
s'il ya des bretons apporter ici vous
êtes peut-être au courant qu'on a
commencé à aller pomper du sable dans la
baie de trébeurden très joli endroit par
ailleurs je vous recommande quelques
noms je les recommande pas parce que
sinon vous allez venir m'embêter quand
j'y suis je n'ai rien dit pas de jolies
mouillage et si on a fait ça c'est tout
simplement parce que les quelques
retraités qui ont envie d'aller
s'installer en bretagne a plus assez de
sable pour faire le béton pour
construire les maisons pour les
retraités donc on est obligé dans les
carrières à terre donc on est obligé
d'aller pomper dans les baies donc vous
pouvez commencer à avoir des stress de
ressources locales et quelque fois ça
peut même aller jusqu'au point où vous
n'êtes pas capables d'aller à terme du
plan vous vous êtes fixé alors il
n'empêche qu'au premier rang aujourd'hui
le seul facteur limitant que nous avons
c'est l'énergie et voilà pourquoi non
pas votre fille est muette mais vous
avez cette courbe qui vous représente
aujourd'hui la meilleure approximation
au premier ordre d'un modèle qui vous
terrorise le pib c'est une droite
extrêmement simple vous avez en entrée
la quantité totale d'énergie que
l'humanité peut extraire de
l'environnement et vous avez en sortie
le pib mondial
voilà ça marche depuis 50 ans à cause de
ce rapport de un à deux sens entre
l'homme et la machine
il ya 50 ans n'est pas un as 200 ça
devait être un as 50 peu importe de
toute façon les hommes deviennent
quantité négligeable dans le pilotage
des flux ou plus exactement ils ne sont
nécessaires que pour piloter les flux de
la machine et donc plus on aura dans un
univers très contraint
ça va plaire à quelques personnes dans
la salle je suis sûr que je vais dire
plus on aura dans un univers contre 1
c'est-à-dire avec peu de flux des
machines très productives ou en plus le
pilotage est faite par des logiciels et
pas par des hommes et moins vous aurez
d'emploi c'est automatique automatique
vous pouvez pas tout avoir en même temps
la raison pour laquelle aujourd'hui la
robotisation et l'emploi vont de pair
c'est que la robotisation permet de
diminuer le coût du travail salariale et
donc dans la compétition mondiale ça
permet de garde de garder les dernières
miettes du gâteau mais ça permettra pas
d'augmenter le gâteau pas du tout autre
conséquence attendue de ce que je viens
de vous raconter donc j'insiste 1 ça
c'est pas la corrélation que j'observe
là qui me prouve ce que je viens de vous
raconter c'est l'exact inverse c'est
parce que vous avez un rapport de 1 à
200 dans le pilotage des flux dont la
contrepartie s'appelle d euros qu il est
normal de trouver une course comme ça
c'est bien dans ce sens là que va le
raisonnement et pas dans l'autre
pareil voilà une courbe attendu avec ce
que je viens de vous raconter ses lacs
aux variations de l'énergie utilisée
dans le monde une année donnée c'est à
dire du parc de machines ou travail et
du pib dans le monde une année donnée
donc le meilleur indicateur avancé de ce
que sera le pays le plus tard c'est la
manière dont l'énergie va évoluer
et ça marche très bien alors ça marche
très bien dans un sens vous avez ici le
pib mondial reconstitué depuis 1 0 alors
entre zéro et 1800 enfants taux zéro est
récent me dit un de mes amis qui a
étudié les moulins de très près donc
jusqu'à l'an mil ça marche la
productivité du travail augmente peu
parce que les auxiliaires techniques et
les exosquelettes ce que les hommes sont
capables de s'adjoindre sont faibles et
donc le pib d'un pays est au premier
rang proportionnel à sa population et
comme la population augmente pas vite
bas le pib augmente pas vite vous
arrivez même par le voir à l'échelle de
cette courbe est donc en première
approximation n'y a pas de croissance
soit dit en passant à ce moment là ya
pas de démocratie non plus
la démocratie apparaît en grande
bretagne deux siècles après que la
grande bretagne ait connu le plus fort
taux de croissance du vieux continent du
vieux continent
il ya peut-être un rapport entre les
deux parce que promettre tout à tout le
monde tout le temps dans un monde qui
est pas en croissance c'est compliqué
donc le maintien de la démocratie dans
un monde sans croissance
ça va être une vraie question qui
commence déjà à se poser aujourd'hui
lien avec des prémices que sont les
votes populiste jusqu'en 1820 une
croissance très élevée et puis arrive
nos auxiliaires nos exosquelette à
combustion interne
et là vous voyez craque c'est parti
alors si on n'avait pas eu les machines
on serait plutôt de ce côté là à
supposer que la population ait pu
croître jusqu'à sept milliards
d'individus sans pétrole et sans gaz
pour augmenter la productivité agricole
ce qui est pas du tout suivi ce qui
n'est pas du tout su et ça marche
particulièrement bien pour le pétrole
vous avez ici une deux courbes depuis
que j'ai trouvé cette covariation ça
marche très très bien donc il suffit de
regarder où va la production de pétrole
sur les cinq à dix ans à venir et vous
avez une bonne idée de là où va aller le
pib mondial sur lesparre personnes sur
les cinq à dix ans à venir
mais à mon avis ça va plutôt ce que vous
avez ici c'est en rouge
la variation alors suis moyenne
glissante sur trois ans de la production
mondiale de pétrole en tonnes
d'accord c'est pas des prix je m'en fous
des prix vous aller voir après que ça
n'a aucune espèce d'importance c'est
layton et en bleu vous avez la variation
à l'échelle mondiale du pib par personne
et bien ce que vous voyez c'est que les
deux co varie depuis les chocs
pétroliers de manière extrêmement serré
mais non seulement sakho varient mais la
variation sur le pétrole précède
légèrement la variation sur le pib par
personne
ça interdit ce que j'ai évoqué tout à
l'heure c'est à dire que le pib croît on
sait pas pourquoi me direz que je gêne
et que du coup ça appelle une
consommation de pétrole parce qu'on est
plus riche en fait ça vous montre bien
que c'est l'inversé qui se passe
d'abord mère-nature vous donne plus de
pétrole du coup vous transformez plus
transporter plus et du coup vous comptez
plus de pib et bien comme ça non c'est
bien 105e
voilà donc le l'économie étant limitées
par
premier
de ces facteurs limitants et à ce moment
il va falloir regarder comment évolue le
facteur limitant qui s'appelle
aujourd'hui l'énergie donc 80% et
fossiles cette énergie fossile a mis des
dizaines de millions d'années à se
constituer donc à l'échelle des temps
historiques on peut considérer que le
stock de départ nous est donnée de
manière fixe donc je vais faire un tout
petit peu de maths
vous avez une fonction de production qui
est une fonction positive c'est
l'extraction des profondeur vers la
surface
d'accord la production ne consiste pas à
remettre des trucs sous le sol
l'extraction des profondeurs vers la
source elle est intégrable entre -9 il y
ait plus d'un fini puisque au plus je
peut extraire ce cas dans le sol et bien
à ce moment les maths bouddhiste sépare
théorème que je sais encore démontré
même mois que sa valeur moyenne sur
n'importe quel intervalle nodules vaut
zéro à moins l'infini 0 à + l'infini et
passe par un maximum absolu entre les
deux d'accord quand je vais vous le dire
avec les mains
quand vous avez un stock de départ qui
est donnée une fois pour toutes vous ne
pouvez pas avoir une extraction de ce
stock qui soit indéfiniment croissante
ni même qui soit indéfiniment constante
en fait c'est obligé d'avoir une tête
qui ressemble à ça donc tout ce stock de
départ qui est donnée une fois pour
toutes qu'il s'agisse du pétrole du gaz
du charbon et du minerai de cuivre du
tungstène du tantale du vanadium du
chrome ou du nickel fera l'objet d'un
pic c'est les maths
ce n'est pas de l'idéologie c'est un
théorème de maths
la bonne question c'est toujours la même
c est ce que j'en suis loin ou pas loin
et est ce que si je le passe ça me fout
tout mon système par terre ou sait même
pas mal je m'en fous et ça c'est une
affaire de substitution possible ou pas
de la ressource
c'est une affaire voilà c'est juste ça
le sujet donc si j'ai un pic mondial sur
le cuivre et que j'ai encore plein
d'aluminium va peut-être que j'arrive
encore à peu près à m'en sortir
par contre si j'ai un pic mondial sur le
pétrole là pour le système de transport
je vois plus de mal à jouer alors plus
de mal
parce que je vous rappelle qu'une
batterie très performante ces quelques
centaines de watts heure par kilo alors
que le pétrole s'est dit kilowattheures
par kilo 12 même pour être plus précis
donc vous avez un facteur 30 entre les
deux et là je vous parle d'une batterie
performante la batterie plomb acide de
votre bagnole c'est plutôt 40 watts
heure par kilo pour savoir si je suis
loin du pic ou pas je peux regarder la
dérive et alors c'est ce que je vais
faire sur le pétrole vous avez ici la
dérive et sur l'extraction pétrolière
depuis un siècle et demi alors c'est une
moyenne glissante sur 10 ans du taux de
progression de la production pétrolière
envoyée il ya un siècle et demi avec des
moyens assez rudimentaire cette
production augmentait de 15 % par an
puissent est descendu à 10 avec des
moyens pourtant plus sophistiqués puis
c'est descendu à 5 avec des moyens
encore plus sophistiquées et aujourd'hui
avec un retour vers le futur puisque le
shale gas et le chai l'oeil c'est connu
depuis deux siècles
eh bien on n'est pas très loin du zéro
et en fait si on comptait correctement
parce que ça s'est fait avec les
statistiques de bp qui met le but à del
et anne dans le pétrole ça se discute un
peu si on comptait correctement en fait
le 0 sur le pétrole conventionnel
on y est depuis 2006 c'est à dire hors
sables bitumineux et chez lloyds depuis
2006 la production est en déclin et
grâce aux sables bitumineux et chez
l'homme
c'est en plateau légèrement ascendant
2006 deux ans avant lehman brothers 2006
deux ans avant lehman brothers tout ça
ne se voit pas dans les prix donc là
aussi je vais revenir sur un peu
d'économie on devrai me dire s'il ya
moins de pétrole bat normalement le
prisme et à faire n'importe quoi
bah non malheureusement ça marche pas
donc tous les gens dans cette salle qui
utilisent d élasticité prix volume sur
une matière première quelle qu'elle soit
pour établir des relations de long terme
utilise quelque chose qui est faux tvo
se constate pas c'est faux
vous avez ici sur le pétrole le volume
proposé sur le marché en abscisse en
millions de tonnes et en ordonnée le
prix du baril sur le marché
en dollars constants alors s'il y avait
une élasticité les points devrait
s'organiser le long de quelque chose qui
ressemble à ça en fait vous constatez
qui a tout sauf une élasticité
vous pouvez avoir des très très grosses
variations de volume à prix constant des
très très grosses variations de prix et
volumes quasiment constant et sur parti
pour un tour en fait si je voulais
théorisé ça je pourrais dire qu'il ya
que deux régimes il reste six cordes
orthogonaux ça ressemble pas vraiment
une élasticité cette histoire et c'est
la raison pour laquelle quand on essaye
de prédire des prix avec des modèles
dans lesquels il a une élasticité ça
vous donne semble donc en bleu vous avez
est ce qu a vraiment été le prix du
pétrole sur un intervalle de 20 ans et
toutes les courbes rouge l'enfer de
couleur pardon sont les prévisions de
prix de l' agence internationale de
l'énergie dur et je crois que maintenant
il faut arrêter d'en faire donc la
dernière fois que monsieur bauza dans le
monde qui a pris ça a fait un papier en
dix ans l'agencé internationale de
l'énergie dit que le prix du pétrole va
rester chez paou pendant les dix ans qui
viennent
je vais envoyer ce graphique en disant
alors comme j'ai été sympa je vais pas
dit vous auriez pu économiser l'encré de
papier du journal
enfin je vais quand même expliqué que
peut-être c'était pas la peine de donner
beaucoup de publicité un travail de
cette qualité il m'a jamais répondu
par contre stéphane foucart qui j'avais
envoyé sa copine m'a envoyé trois mails
est évidemment quand vous voyez ça vous
vous dites que ça ne vaut pas l'encré et
le papier du journal pour parler de ce
que sort les yeux ou alors vous sortez
un papier en dix ans alors que ça fait
20 ans qu'ils racontent n'importe quoi
les yeux il n'y a pas plus de lien entre
le prix du pétrole et le pib mondial
vous avez ici le pib mondial
en dollars constants sur l'axé vertical
et le prix du baril en dollars constants
sur l'axé horizontal depuis 1960 même
pareil si quand le prix du pétrole monte
le pib devait souffrir les points devra
être qu'elle se ressembler à quelque
chose comme ça et vous voyez que vous
pouvez avoir le pib qui augmente avec le
prix qui baissent le pib qui augmente
avec le prix qui montent qui augmente
avec le prix qui baissent qui augmente
avec le prix qu'ils montrent aucun lien
il n'y a aucun lien
il ya un lien sur le partage de la rente
ça c'est absolument certain l'argent va
pas dans les mêmes poches mais sur le
pib mondial
il n'y a aucun lien aucun 0 donc les
prix on s'en fout ce qui compte c'est
les volumes alors je vous remonte le
graphique que je vous ai montré tout à
l'heure mais cette fois ci je vais pas
l'interpréter de la même manière entre
le début de cette série statistique
jeguirim bois qui sert très peu aux
machines et les chocs pétroliers
vous voyez que l'énergie disponible par
personne et par an augmente de 2 et demi
pour cent par an ça veut dire quoi cette
histoire ça veut dire que en fait le
parc de machines augmente d'au moins
deux et demi pour cent par personne et
par an c'est ça que ça veut dire
parc de machines au travail donc la
quantité de ressources transformer
augmente d'au moins deux et demi pour
cent par personne et par an et donc le
pib augmente d'au moins deux et demi
pour cent par personne et par an
première fin de la fête après les chocs
pétroliers vous voyez un changement de
dérivés sur l'approvisionnement
énergétique mondial en fait
contrairement à ce qu'on pensait
énormément d'économistes et à ce que
pensait le lecteur de journal que
j'étais ya 20 ans on disait le choc
pétrolier c'est le prix devient élevé
puis le prix on redevient un bras puis
dormez tranquilles bonnes gens c'est
comme si s'était rien passé
ça c'est retour à l'état antérieur mais
non pas du tout en fait ça a remarqué un
changement de dérivés on n'est pas du
tout revenu à l'état antérieur
on s'est retrouvé avec un écart
structurel entre les promesses de
redistribution que tous les états
providence de l'occident avait fait à
toute leur population
est ce que la productivité physique du
travail pouvait vraiment faire après
c'est à dire beaucoup moins et donc on
s'est retrouvé dans tous les pays
occidentaux avec des problèmes de
chômage et dette
partout en même temps parce que si ça
avait été juste dû à la nullité et à
l'incurie d'un représentant élu ce qu'on
appelle un politique
eh bien il aurait dû être
particulièrement crasse ici est
particulière embryons là mais c'est pas
du tout ce qui est constaté
ça a été partout pareil et vous savez
quand le résultat d'une expérience est
indépendant d'un des paramètres c'est
que ce paramètre compte pas dans
l'expérience
donc n'attendez pas des élus qu'ils
soient capables de maîtriser la physique
ils le font pas ils ne le font pas parce
qu'ils ne le peuvent pas
et puis depuis 2005
ça commence à devenir particulièrement
salée et à ce moment on à explosion de
la dette etc
alors maintenant je vais vous montrer
pourquoi en europe la croissance ne
reviendra pas c'est là que je voulais
finir par là je voulais finir cet exposé
sur l'énergie voilà l'approvisionnement
pétrolier de l'europe
l'approvisionnement pétrolier de
l'europe et la somme de 2 terme la
production domestique en rose qui a
passé son pic depuis longtemps de bill
et les approvisionnements importés en
verre dont vous voyez que ils ont
augmenté transitoirement entre le pic
européen et 2006 et après 2006 ils se
sont mis à décliner alors 2015 2014 2015
2016 vous avez eu une telle envolée du
shale oil aux états unis que ça a permis
de remonter alors que cette industrie
perd de l'argent
c'est un mystère le shale oil aux états
unis cette industrie perd de l'argent il
n'y a pas eu un dollars de cash flow
positif gagné par cette industrie depuis
le début pas 1 250 milliards de dollars
au moins de pertes cumulées depuis le
début cash flow négatif
et pourtant ça continue bon voilà enfin
bref c'est un petit d'ailleurs une
pyramide de ponzi là dedans mais
l'approvisionnement a réaugmenté c'est
pour ça que vous voyez une petite queue
de hausse là sur la fin mais sinon voyez
que ça descend structurellement et le
truc va repartir à la baisse dans pas
très longtemps
sas a aussi été provoqué par un surplus
d'investissement lié au fait que le
baril était à 140 dollars
maintenant que le baril est à 50 ou à
40,20 celle inverse vous avez un défaut
d'investissement d'axa repartir dans
l'autre sens près vous avez du gaz en
europe
alors là le gaz vous voyez que
contrairement aux thermes qui vient
toujours à l'esprit des gens quand on
parle gaz c'est à dire russie en fait 60
% de l'approvisionnement européen en gaz
de la mer du nord mais la mer du nord a
passé son pic depuis 2005 et on ne peut
pas compenser rapidement par des
importations parce que poser un tuyau
qui s'appelle un gazoduc sam et 20 ou 30
ans et construire un train de
liquéfaction de gaz et des terminaux de
gazéification c'est une opération qui
est lourde
avec en plus maintenant de plus en plus
des gens qui disent qu'ils n'en veulent
pas dans leurs jardins pouvaient faire
du gaz de schiste si ça vous amuse en
plus je pense qu'il y en a pas sûr qu'il
en est voilà l'ordre de grandeur de ce
qui est en cause donc ça va pas changer
la tendance lourde
après vous pouvez utiliser du charbon il
se trouve que la production de charbon
en europe a été divisé par trois depuis
1981 c'est pas à cause du changement
climatique c'est juste parce que ça fait
deux siècles qu'on tape dedans et donc
il y aura de moins en moins et la chaîne
religieuse logistique du charbon est
tellement lourde que vous compenser ça
passe à part des importations non plus
parce que faut rajouter des terminaux
charbonnier des minéraliers machette et
un alors maintenant on regarde
l'approvisionnement européen tout
compris vous voyez que il est constitué
de charbon qui est en déclin géologique
de pétrole qui est en déclin géologique
locale plus sans plafonnement mondiale
et donc on en a de moins en moins parce
que les chinois n'ont plus en plus de
gaz qui est en déclin géologique de
nucléaire pour lequel on a le
trouillomètre à zéro et de nouvelles
énergies renouvelables alors je
reviendrai pas dessus aujourd'hui que
j'ai pas le temps mais dont l'intensité
capitalistique en fait quand vous
regardez bien est un ordre de grandeur
au dessus de ce que c'est pour le
nucléaire
si vous prenez en compte tous les effets
donc c'est pas avec ça que vous allez
compenser tout le reste et vous voyez
que le maximum a été passé en 2006 2006
deux ans avant lehman brothers
maintenant je vous la fait courte mais
bonne 2006 début du déclin de
l'approvisionnement énergétique
ralentissement du pib retournement des
prix de l'immobilier aux états unis à
cause du ralentissement du pib et à ce
moment faillite du système financier
c'est dans ce sens là que les choses se
sont passées donc d'été bien le début du
retournement de l'approvisionnement
énergétique à venir sur le pétrole parce
que c'est ça à mon avis qui va précéder
de pas beaucoup la prochaine crise
financière
pour les mêmes raisons
alors voilà ce que ça donne au niveau
des états unis pardon au niveau de la
prochainement par personne et vous voyez
au niveau de l'approvisionnement par
personne en europe vous avez donc de
temps la fin des trente glorieuses
s'arrête d'augmenter entre la fin des
trente glorieuses et 2006 est stable et
après 2006 abbès et voilà maintenant la
variation du pib par personne en europe
les trente glorieuses à cause de
l'approvisionnement énergétique
rapidement croissant s'est rapidement
croissant pendant ce qu'on a appelé les
trente piteuses là vous avez le gain
d'efficacité énergétique
mais c'est tout et puis depuis 2006
tombe à zéro sauf que dans leurs grands
génies les européens ont dit nous allons
faire un projet qui est une très bonne
idée
nous allons faire la paix ce qui est une
très bonne idée et pour bien
matérialiser le fait qu'on va faire la
paix on faire un marché unique ça
c'était une moins bonne idée vous faites
un marché unique dans lequel vous dit
tout le monde a le droit de se balader
partout les gens ont le droit d'investir
partout et vous fait un gâteau qui
globalement n'augmente plus mais avec
des énormes différences de potentiel sur
les revenus par personne entre l'est et
l'ouest
que croyez-vous qu'il advint et bien
l'industriel de l'ouest investi à l'est
le plombier de l'est var à londres tout
ça est parfaitement normal et c'est un
jeu à somme nulle
donc ce que les uns et les autres ne
l'ont plus et on demande aux anglais
s'il trouve ça drôle et disent non c'est
exactement pour les mêmes raisons que
les gens votent avec leurs pieds partout
et ça va continuer c'est à dire que dans
un univers en contraction ou le français
continue à gagner quatre ou cinq fois ce
que gagne le roumain dans un univers de
libre marché
ça va continuer il ya aucune raison que
ça ne continue pas je suis pas en train
de dire que les roumains sont des
abrutis une partie de ma famille on
vient mais je suis juste en train de
vous dire ce qui est en train de se
passer est normal dans un univers qui
est physiquement contre un avec une
liberté de circulation à l'intérieur du
système et des grosses différences de
potentiel au départ donc aujourd'hui si
vous voulez vraiment l'europe vous devez
accepter de donner la moitié ce que vous
gagnez aux mains voilà c'est ça qui a
aidé charge pour pâques
une seule seconde que le système fasse
égalisé avec le roumain qui va se mettre
à gagner ce que vous gagnez vous avec la
contrainte énergétique que nous avons je
répète tout c'est bon non je traduit en
anglais c'est pas nécessaire alors vous
voyez qu'au pays de trump même motif
même punition fin des chocs pétroliers
2006 en fait chez eux le problème a
démarré en 2000 ans j'ai pas exactement
pourquoi mail a démarré en 2000 quand
vous regardez le taux d'emploi aux états
unis par exemple c'est à dire la
fraction des adultes âgés de plus de 15
ans qui ont un job c'est en 2000 que ça
a été maximum sur la période qui va de
2000 à 2016
aujourd'hui encore le taux d'emploi je
pars pas du taux de chômage on s'en fout
parce que ça inclut les gens qui disent
qu'ils veulent un emploi
moi je regarde juste la fraction de la
population âgée de plus de 15 ans qui a
un emploi aux etats unis c'est lé de
quatre points inférieurs aujourd'hui à
ce qu'elle était en 2000 donc quand on
dit les états unis ont réglé leur
problème de chômage
ils l'ont notamment régler en faisant en
sorte qu'une partie des gens qui ont pas
de job disent qu'ils n'en veulent plus
c'est comme ça qu'ils ont réglé une
partie du problème
enfin voila vous voyez pas une
différence notable en termes d'évolution
et vous voyez exactement le même
résultat
alors maintenant où allons nous et bien
voilà à quoi ressemble
l'approvisionnement énergétique passé de
notre beau pays
vous voyez c'est la courbe plein
et puis deux manières de la prolonger la
manière électorale c'est le train fin
aux le très fin pardon en eau alors
c'est la manière électorale quand on
vous promet la croissance du pib
le trait pointillés en bas c'est la
manière quand on vous promet l'accord de
paris si je suis un peu taquin et en
fait c'est à mon avis plus proche de ce
qui va vraiment se passer alors c'est
quoi le trait en bas c'est non pas en
prolongeant le taux de croissance ou
l'accroissement arithmétique moyens si
en prolongeant la dérivée seconde
là je me suis amusé à faire des
prolongations de dérivés seconde c'est à
dire d'accélération je me suis dit ce
qui représente la dynamique du système
c'est l'accélération
donc je prolonge la dérivée seconde donc
la variation la variation excellent fait
très bien ça à la place donc c'est la
courbe pointillés que je vous montre là
ça prolonge accélération et à mon avis
c'est beaucoup plus proche de ce qu'il
va finir par se passer que le très fin
du haut alors je peux jouer à ce jeu là
avec l'europe aussi voyez je peux jouer
à ce jeu là avec les états unis avec la
td au pardon et je peux jouer à ce jeu
là avec le monde dans son ensemble à
chaque fois ma dérivée seconde est
suffisamment négative pour que le plus
vraisemblable c'est que accords de paris
ou pas encore de pareil de toute façon
je vais buté sur la limite des
ressources est ce que l'accord de paris
me demanderait de faire ses 10 buts et
encore plus vite
pour la partie énergie
du coup la vienne s'opposer deux visions
de manière brutale vous avez ici le pib
passer de l'europe
alors il est reconstituée en 1960 parce
qu'en 1960 ya pas encore la république
tchèque d'un côté et la république
slovaque de l'autre et l'ensemble ne
fait pas vraiment partie de l'europe
mais enfin l'union européenne met donc
s'est reconstitué et vous avez pour
l'avenir 3 manière de prolonger ses
rangs vous pouvez faire comme ferez
votre gamin il prend une règle il
prolonge le trait voilà pour la manière
de faire vous avez ce que souvent la
manière intuitive une deuxième manière
c'est de prolonger le taux de croissance
moyen géométriques une belle
exponentielle le rouge et vous pouvez
prolonger la dynamique la dérivée
seconde est à ce moment vous avez le
pointillé du bain évidemment ça vous
donne pas la même base de travail pour
savoir ce que vous allez pouvoir donner
à qui voit là et ça marche avec les
autres zones que j'ai évoquées alors à
sa vient se rajouter un problème et j'ai
pas le temps d'en parler aujourd'hui
parce que j'ai été trop long sur le
changement climatique j'ai rien face il
ya des questions et je vais aller
directement
ah ça c'est la fin de l'histoire sur
changement climatique vous avez ici une
courbe qui sort du dernier rapport du
giec
alors pour ceux d'entre vous qui ne
savent pas un rapport du giec
aujourd'hui ça fait 6000 pages
si je mets les trois tomes il n'y a pas
une personne qui l'invoquent qu'il a lui
même pas moins j'en ai lu un morceau
mais pas tous j'ai par contre lui les
trois résumé technique chacun 100 pages
et la majeure partie des gens quand il
parle du rapport du giec qui en fait ils
visent le résumé pour décideurs qui fait
20 ou 30 pages et qui contient
évidemment des conclusions est
absolument pas d'explication parce qu'on
20 ou 30 pas je n'ai pas le temps
d'expliquer
sinon vous envers de riez pas à faire un
truc qui ont fait 6000 il n'a pas jour
partie enfin pardon la quasi totalité
sinon la totalité des gens qui disent
que ce qu'il ya dedans et n'importe quoi
tant que le premier nous le long
évidemment pas plus lui c'est un objet
de fantasme beaucoup plus qu'un objet
étudiés donc vous avez ici un graphique
qui sort du dernier rapport du giec et
qui vous donne un certain nombre de
simulations dans des courbes de couleurs
différentes qui vous donne l'élévation
de température planétaire que vous avez
entre l'époque préindustrielle et 2100
en fonction de l'évolution des émissions
cumulées entre l'ère préindustrielle et
2100 alors si les émissions cumulées
s'arrête à 3000 votre courbe elle va pas
au delà de 3000 en 2100 puis si ça va
jusqu'à 7000 c'est l'accès à leurs
applications numériques et vous voyez
que l'ensemble de ces cours pour une
droite en fait donc vous avez une
relation linéaire entre eux l'élévation
de température entre le pré industrielle
et 2100 et les émissions cumulées
entreprises industrielles et de mix ans
donc en gros ce que vous acceptez comme
élévation de température
c'est une fonction linéaire de la
quantité totale de co2 que vous avez
envie de mettre dans l'atmosphère aussi
con que ça donc applications numériques
à fin 2015
nous avons mis deux mille milliards de
tonnes de co2 dans l'atmosphère et donc
on a signé pour un degré quelque chose
sauf à ce que les émissions deviennent
nul dans les dix ans qui viennent
je peux vous dire que les 1,5 degré ou
les oubliés c'est terminé
fily fallait y penser avant et s'il
fallait y penser avant pour une
excellente raison que je vais quand même
vous donner ici c'est que le temps de
résidence du co2 ou plus exactement du
surplus de concentration de co2 dans
l'atmosphère
ce conte comme je l ai dit tout à
l'heure en dizaines de milliers d'années
vous avez ici un graphique qui vous
donne l'amortissement d'un surplus de
co2 donc vous augmenter la concentration
de co2 dans l'atmosphère à thé 0 1 par
exemple vous vous prenez l'état actuel
et vous vous arrêter d'émettre
et puis vous regardez le temps qu'il
faut pour amortir ce surplus de
concentration et bien ce que vous disent
ces graphiques c'est que au bout d'un
siècle
vous en avez toujours 40% qui au dessus
de vos têtes du surplus au bout d'un
millénaire vous en avez toujours 20% et
en fait il faut attendre plus de dix
mille ans pour que ce surplus de co2 que
nous avons déjà créé s'évacue en
totalité si on arrête d'émettre du co2
demain matin donc je suis en train de
vous répondre de vous dire là c'est que
vu les échelles de temps qui caractérise
non seulement une génération humaine
mais un mandat en démocratie nous sommes
sur un problème qui n'a aucune espèce de
réversibilité aucune ce qui est notre
manière de dire que le jour où vous vous
dites merde j'aurais pas dû comme petit
gibus si j'avais su j'aurais pas venu
c'est fini pour éviter les conséquences
qui ont commencé à vous déplaire à ce
moment là c'est terminé pour attraper
pas le coup c'est un peu comme si vous
sautez un jour vous êtes un peu déprimé
du troisième étage de la tour eiffel
et puis arrivé au niveau du premier
étage vous dites merde j'aurais
peut-être pas dû l'image est pas trop
forte
c'est exactement ça il n'y a aucune
capacité à remettre le système en l'état
aucune insiste aucune et tous les gens
qui pensent qu'on va faire avec la
géo-ingénierie quelques tripatouillages
de thermostats là pour y arriver sera se
raconte des carabistouilles parce que
l'énergétique interne du système est tel
que vous y arriverez pas
donc je reviens à ce que je disais sur
mon budget carbone donc vous êtes
aujourd'hui là et si vous dites je
respecte les deux degrés et vous avez
bien compris que c'est peu de gens qu'on
avait envie au fond
eh bien vous raisonnez à l'envers vous
dit bah voila je pars de la et crac j'ai
le droit d'émettre 3000 milliards de
tonnes de co2 accumulés dont deux villes
ont déjà été émises donc j'ai encore on
a 1000 donc les plus jeunes dans cette
salle vous avez droit pour le restant de
votre vie des maîtres tous ensemble que
vous êtes quelques milliards sur cette
planète
la moitié de ce que les gens qui ont les
cheveux gris dans cette salle ont émis
pendant le siècle qui a précédé alors
qu'ils étaient en moyenne trois fois
moins nombreux
voilà c'est ça l'équation
dit autrement vous avez droit à un
sixième du budget carbone de vos
arrières grands parents est assez simple
et si on ne fait pas ça il n'ya pas les
2 degrés est décidé de faire ça s'est
décidé de s'y mettre très sérieusement
dans les 20 ou 30 ans qui viennent en
fait la trajectoire qui permet
d'atteindre ce genre de résultat c'est
d'avoir des émissions mondiales qui
deviennent nul quelque part dans la
deuxième moitié du xxième siècle
c'est ça le le cahier des charges on va
dire donc le cahier des charges c'est
que tout ce qui aujourd'hui a fait la
productivité du travail
le gain du pouvoir d'achat les 35 heures
les six semaines de congés payés la
retraite à 65 ans bien payés etc etc
tout ça est remis en cause par le fait
qu' il faut très très violemment
comprimé l'approvisionnement énergétique
mondial et donc la productivité mondiale
voilà c'est ça l'équation est donc
maintenant vous comprenez probablement
un peu mieux pourquoi est-ce que ça fait
23 coop qu'on n'arrive pas à se mettre
d'accord mais on ne peut pas se mettre
d'accord de manière consensuelle sur un
truc comme ça c'est un peu comme si
j'essayais de vous faire voter à main
levée la maintenant les quelques
centaines de personnes dans la salle
donc on est à peu près au même nombre
c'est même ordre de grandeur que les
nations unies il ya 200 ans pays un
essai un pays une voix donc les îles
tuvalu ça coûte ça compte comme les
états unis
c'est comme si maintenant on l'a à main
levé j'ai essayé de fous rires
mettre d'accord sur la manière de
répartir une baisse globale de vos
rémunérations de 50%
voilà et je vous dis dans une heure là
chacun d'entre vous individuellement de
manière volontaire de manière volontaire
et non contrainte
vous êtes d'accord sur ce que sera votre
baisse à vous ça vous donne une idée du
cahier des charges
je peux vous donner un autre exemple
c'est comme si dans une assemblée de
copropriétaires où il ya 200
copropriétaires vous dites il va y avoir
des travaux à faire je vous donne pas
exactement le montant et le temps de
l'assemblée des copropriétaires j'essaye
de vous mettre d'accord sur la façon de
répartir les travaux bon ben voilà il ya
pas plus de chance d'y arriver c'est ça
une copains c'est exactement ce genre
d'exercice il n'y a pas de chef
voilà et enfin pour finir de vous
embrouiller un peu l'esprit donc je vais
vous dire deux choses la première c'est
celle là
en gros si je raisonne climat en sortie
de cet exposé et bien ou bien je ne veux
pas agir et à ce moment je vais avoir
une perte accélérée de ressources
naturelles que j'aurais de toute façon à
cause du système économique qu'il a été
organisée mais j'accélère le problème et
à ce moment je veux prendre des dommages
physiques
alors quand lord stern a dit ça nous
coûtera 6 % du pib c'est une vaste
blague
il aurait dit qu'à tout 80 c'était
pareil puisqu'il a utilisé un instrument
qui compte les ressources pour zéro pour
théoriser le dommages faits aux
ressources
moi je veux bien si ça les amuse ça a
fait beaucoup de bien aux débats dans le
monde économique
parce que dans le monde économique tant
qu'on parle pas de rohan n'existe pas il
n'empêche que en termes strictement
académique son truc vaut pas un clou
mais c'est pas grave ça fait du bien et
puis si vous voulez agir à ce moment
vous vous retrouvez avec le risque si
symétrique qui est le risque de casser
le système en voulant agir trop vite
donc si vous n'agissez pas vous risquez
de casser le système parce que vous
agissez pas si vous agissez trop vite
vous risquez de casser le système parce
que vous agissiez trop vite voilà je
choisis ton camp camarade
et en plus le sépare de renoncer parce
que je voulais vous montrer et en plus
le déterminant des causes et je veux en
finir avec ça est compliqué vous avez
ici un graphique qui vous donne
l'évolution de la quantité de co2 km
dans l'atmosphère pour faire 1 dollars
de pib en europe
alors vous voyez que le temps de cette
série qui démarre en 65
cet indicateur a été divisée par 3 vivre
nos les européens après je regarde ce
qui s'est passé aux états unis et je
vois que le temps de cette série cet
indicateur a été divisée par 3
là je me dis ah ça doit être un peu plus
compliqué cette histoire que simplement
leurs représentants politiques du moment
qui dit qu'il va s'attaquer au problème
ou pas ou pas en fait
à court terme c'est un déterminant du
deuxième ordre
si ce n'est du troisième c'est bien ça
le problème voilà j'arrête de vous
enquiquiner avec mes graphiques
compliqué et je vais aller directement
à la fin c'est à dire à la question de
l'action je vous ai dit tout ça alors
j'anticipe une question qui m'a mais de
poser comme ça ça soulagera l'élu dans
cette salle enfin les élus dans cette
salle en général en sortie de ce genre
d'exposer il ya toujours quelqu'un qui
le dit mais que fait la police
le prouvent les dirigeants politiques ne
s'en occupe pas or il ya plein de
raisons pour lesquelles ils ont vaincu
pas une des raisons pour lesquelles ils
s'en occupent pas c'est parce que vous
ne le voulait pas une des raisons
alors vous pouvez ne pas le vouloir
parce que vous ignorez que le problème
existe et vous pouvez ne pas le vouloir
parce qu'une fois que vous avez compris
que le problème existait vous dites
waouh je crois sûr que l'on s'en
occupera demain d'accord et il ya une
autre raison
en fait enfin une autre réponse à cette
question qui est de ne pas comprendre la
différence entre un système politique
est un organisme professionnel dans
lequel on est baigné au quotidien donc
dans votre univers profesionnel
quotidien vous avez un patron d'accor le
patron il décide et vous avez sous les
patrons des gens qui exécutent alors le
patron a toujours un petit pouvoir
coercitif sur les gens qui sont censés
exécuté il est petit ou il est important
mais il est toujours présent d'accord ça
peut être un arbitrage budgétaire
ça peut être l'autorisation de recruter
quelqu'un ça peut être au contraire la
possibilité de vous virer
même s'il ya un programme derrière enfin
voilà patron il a un droit et puis donc
si vous faites la mauvaise tête de temps
en temps le patron à quelques moyens
coercitifs alors dans un système
politique on se dit c'est pareil
là on en a élu un il est jeune il est
beau il est cueilli etc il a nous régler
le problème en deux temps trois
mouvements alors en fait c'est pas
comprendre qu'en fait le patron il est
là dans un système politique
c'est un système d'une pyramide inversée
un système politique
d'accord c'est les salariés qui commande
dans un système politique
donc il y en a qui veulent ceux ci
d'autres qui veulent cela d'autres
encore qui veulent cela d'autres encore
qui veulent cela et d'autres encore qui
veulent cela qu'il ya tout ça sur les
épaules hippie démerde toi
tant que les gens qui sont à l'étagé au
dessus en démocratie ce sont pas mis
d'accord avec eux mêmes
vous n'avez aucune chance aucune chance
que à l'étagé en dessous c'est à dire
chez les élus qui sont en fait
partiellement des exécuteurs
testamentaires
rappelez-vous mitterrand ces
propositions qu'il se devait de mettre
en oeuvre au long des ces propositions
il a voulu faire pareil se devait de
mettre un doigt bien mettre en oeuvre
ses exécuteurs testamentaires
et bien pour partie et bien
tant que vous vous êtes pas mis d'accord
avec vous même il n'y a aucune chance
que le système politique se met en route
dans les bon ordre de grandeur
donc en fait c'est ça le grand drame des
démocraties cd système lent et quand on
est dans une course contre la montre
c'est pas très adapté mais comme disait
churchill
tout le reste est pire donc le problème
dans lequel on est aujourd'hui c'est
qu'on a notre petit vaisseau spatial qui
s'appelle la planète terre qui fonce
droit vers les environnements avec une
assemblée générale des colocataires du
vaisseau qui fait de temps en temps une
grande délibération pour savoir qui aura
le droit de prendre les commandes et
puis ça change tous les deux ans pour
essayer de prendre des mesures
drastiques qui vont faire encaisser 15g
à tout l'équipage dont une partie ne
survivra pas voilà c'est donc face est
compliqué voilà l'équation de cette
affaire-là est extrêmement compliqué et
si je n'ai qu'un seul message à vous
livrer en sortie de cette intervention
c'est avant d'être sûr de votre coup sur
la manière dont vous avez envie de
proposer une solution documentez-vous
bien parce que c'est compliqué il n'y a
pas de solution simple pas de solution
simple il n'y a pas de silver bullet
suffit pas de dire ceci cela rien par
contre la seule bonne nouvelle qu'on a
dans cette histoire c'est que le leader
du monde libre a dit ce problème ne
m'intéresse pas c'est la seule bonne
nouvelle qu'on est dans cette histoire
est donc comme les français ont une
tradition historique d'être plutôt pas
mauvais dans l'optimisation sous
contrainte
moi j'ai envie de dire ça c'est quand
même une bonne nouvelle pour nous donc
la seule chose que moi j'aurais envie de
dire si je soufflais dans l'oreille d'un
politique ces fonds sont dessus parce
que de toute façon c'est une mesure sans
regret merci
est-ce que la seule solution ne serait
pas une dictature verte
vous pouvez nous en sommes le problème
des dictatures c'est qu'il faut être sûr
de bien choisir mes dictateur et si vous
faites le mauvais choix vous avez pas
tellement de mesures nous votre four en
arrière comme je l ai dit il ya trente
secondes il n'y a pas une bonne mesure
dans cette histoire il ya une tout un
ensemble de votre mesure
ce qui est sûr c'est que le risque a
laissé le système se résoudre de lui
même c'est qu'à mon avis il emportera la
démocratie au passage pas sûr est ce que
vous faites cet exposé une fois par mois
à l'assemblée nationale non parce que
comme je l' ai dit tout à l'heure
l'assemblée nationale c'est le bas de la
pyramide donc l'assemblée nationale est
incapable de faire quoi que ce soit de
ce genre d'exposer tant que le haut de
la pyramide c'est à dire l'électorat n'a
pas envie d'en faire quelque chose
donc ce qu'on peut faire quand même des
choses à l'assemblée nationale mais on
peut pas il fait la révolution contre le
peuple
il ya une chose que pardon donc on peut
il pousser des mesures mais c'est des
mesures incrémentale nécessairement j'ai
une remarque pour les ressources
il y en a quand même une qui est
relativement limitée illimité sur à peu
près sans quelques d'autres centaines
millions d'années c'est le rayonnement
du soleil
le problème évidemment c'est comment
utiliser cette ressource illimitée dans
un temps très court
le problème du soleil c'est pas
tellement le volume global de la
ressource accessible c'est le fait que
ça aura pas une très forte densité
d'énergie et ce que j'ai expliqué tout à
l'heure avec mon parallèle vent et
pétrole en fait j'aurais pu le faire
avec soleil et pétrole c'est exactement
la même la même équation
c'est à dire que du soleil vous en avez
beaucoup mais encore une fois c'est
c'est diffus et donc la quantité de
travail humain qu'il faut pour le
concentré le stocker et le rendre
pilotable s'est considérablement plus
importants que ce que vous avez pour le
pétrole
sinon historiquement comme on a disposé
du soleil avant de disposer du pétrole
s'il y avait eu des qualités
thermodynamique mans supérieure pour le
soleil on n'aurait jamais utilisé
pétrole on sait pas emmerdé à le faire
il sera pas été utile ma question était
la suivante c'est que vous avez pris en
compte essentiellement dans le
réchauffement climatique et dans la
possibilité de l'arrêter
l'intervention humaine les faits en
mouvement mais il y a eu déjà dans
l'histoire des réchauffements
climatiques qui se sont arrêtées et qui
ont ensuite été suivi d'un
refroidissement et je pense et je
regrette que dans les exposés comme le
vôtre home ne fasse pas état de ces de
ces phénomènes et on ne compare pas le
phénomène actuel avec les phénomènes
naturels qui se sont déjà passés et rien
ne dit que le phénomène actuel n'est pas
un phénomène naturel qui ressemble à de
multiples phénomène identique qui ont
lieu dans l'histoire il ya plein de
choses qui disent que ça ne ressemble
pas ce qui s'est passé dans l'histoire
je vais vous en donner 2 alors d'abord
j'ai fait deux heures c'était déjà long
donc je me suis limité à 2 heures vous
avez un cours en ligne que je fais aux
mines depuis dix ans un des modules
porte sur la question du réchauffement
climatique donc je vous invite à aller
le voir et là vous avez deux heures et
demi rien que sur la question que vous
avez évoqué d'autres
l'énergie que la terre reçoit vient
uniquement du soleil donc si le
réchauffement été provoqué par des
causes naturelles
la première d'entre elles serait une
augmentation de la quantité d'énergie
soleil de salaire par donc on reçoit il
se trouve que cette énergie solaire se
compose pour partie d'ultra violets donc
si c'est l'énergie solaire qui augmente
quand la terre se réchauffe
on reçoit plus de rayonnement solaire
est notamment plus ultra violets ci est
donc à ce moment là vous avez la
puissance solaire qui augmente ça c'est
une rétroaction du système aussi oui
mais je sais une rétroaction du système
quand vous chauffer l'eau le co2 qu'elle
contient sous forme 10 août est moins
bien dissous le co2 s'évacue mais pour
ça faut commencer par chauffer l'eau
donc faut en venir à l'explication que
je viens vous gérez vous donnez donc
vous avez la puissance solaire qui
augmente et donc vous recevez notamment
plus d'ultra violets et ça ça vous
réchauffe la stratosphère parce que
c'est là que se trouve l'ozone qui
intercepte les ultraviolets donc si le
réchauffement devait être provoqué par
le soleil la première chose que vous
devriez observer si un réchauffement de
la stratosphère or on observe
actuellement en refroidissement la
deuxième chose que vous devriez observer
c'est que la température augmente plus
vite là où il ya du soleil que là où il
y en a pas c'est à dire aux tropiques au
pôle or actuellement on observe que le
réchauffement augmente plus vite au pôle
qu aux tropiques ce qui est totalement
incompatible avec le fait que ce soit un
surplus d'énergie solaire qui réchauffe
la terre donc vous avez aujourd'hui des
observations spatiales et temporelles
qui vous permettent de dire que c'est
absolument certain que ça n'est pas une
cause externe au système climatique qui
provoque le forçage qu'on est en train
d'observer aujourd'hui et vous en avez
d'autres
donc aujourd'hui c'est très bien
documenté donc aller lire les quelques
milliers de pages du rapport du giec et
s'il ya un truc ciciba fait le parce que
c'est comme ça que la science avance et
donc s'il ya quelque chose dans ces
quelques milliers de pages qui vous
déplaît et bien vous prenez votre belle
plume et vous écrivez un papier
scientifique en expliquant pourquoi
est-ce que ce que vous avez lu page 352
du rapport du giec vous déplaît vous
l'envoyez à une revue scientifique et il
le publierons si ce que vous dites est
juste
[Applaudissements]
bonjour et merci de votre présentation
vous parlais tout à l'heure de
documenter correctement sur les
solutions possibles
je voulais avoir votre avis sur les
centres à la capture de carbone qui sont
notamment expérimenté actuellement en
ayant chang en chine sur lesquels j'ai
vraiment du mal à me documenter
quand je connais pas le jeu connaît pas
le l'exemple chinois
par contre ce que je peux vous donner
c'est les principes globaux ce qu'on
appelle capture et séquestration du co2
c'est la possibilité de récupérer en
sortie de centrales électriques
essentiellement on y pense aussi pour
les aciéries les cimenteries de
récupérer les fumées d'épurer le co2
qu'elles contiennent
alors pour ça on fait passer les fumées
sur un des solvants qui s'appelle d
amine
à ce moment les amines absorbent le co2
on récupère les amines on l'aimé en
univers confiné on les chauffe donc faux
de l'énergie et à ce moment où des
sorgues le co2 qu on compresse qu'on
liquéfie enfin tombé sous forme
supercritique etc ont enfoui sous le sol
dans lequel on le fait diffuser dans une
couche géologique profonde typiquement
des aquifères salins ou des trucs comme
ça alors ça suppose plusieurs choses de
pouvoir mettre en oeuvre ce procédé
ça suppose d'abord d'avoir le surplus de
consommation énergétique disponible sur
site
donc si vous avez une centrale
électrique ça vous ampute votre
production électrique de 20 % donc ou
bien en face vous l'acceptez où vous
l'acceptez pas à ce moment pour
augmenter le charbon ou le gaz qui
rentrent de 30%
c'est plus ou moins facile ensuite ça
suppose d'avoir un endroit où enfouir le
co2 alors si vous êtes en chine vous dit
à la population c'est comme ça on
discute pas si vous êtes en europe la
population discute donc vous avez mettre
un certain temps
avant d'y arriver faut avoir la couche
géologique qui s'y prêtent donc si votre
centrale et sur un bassin sédimentaire
c'est facile à trouver si elle est sur
un socle granitique c'est plus compliqué
à ce moment faut le transporter sur des
longues distances et enfin les débits
d'injection sont limitées par puits donc
c'est un peu comme pour le gaz de
schiste mais dans l'autre sens faut
multiplier les têtes d'injection pour
être capable de faire rentrer le co2
sous le sol rapidement alors je crois
que moi j'avais entendu parler d'un
système opérationnel sur une centrale de
quelques centaines de mégawatts aux
états unis donc ça marche physiquement
il n'y a pas de sujet là dessus mais les
contreparties sont celles que je viens
de dire
faut être capable de rapidement dire à
la population il y aura un tuyau qui
passera à puis c'est comme ça pour le
bien du climat il faut être capable de
rapidement dire à la population il ya 20
% d'électricité en moins et puis c'est
comme ça il faut être
voilà c'est ça le sait mais on sait
faire à petite échelle
donc oui gens que j'ai bien voici votre
exposé puis qui est des modèles
physiques mais je ne suis pas tout à
fait convaincu par les extrapolations à
2115 là et en plus prendre la dérivée
seconde c'est toujours quelque chose qui
me chagrine pourquoi pas les tuer en
tout cas dans tous les modèles physiques
que l'économie prend il n'ya jamais il
ya des noues sur l' équilibre mais je
mets deux notions de feedback
quels sont les paramètres qu'on pourrait
injecter à la source préfecture en avoir
un pseudo équilibre et de temps en temps
je me demande si l'économie et le su
provoquer turn est une science à banon
enfin ça dépend ça peut faire l'objet
d'un processus d'ordre scientifique
c'est à dire d'une réfutation par le
père sauf qu'aujourd'hui come on come
c'est une comme ça alors je vais être un
peu méchant mais quand même on va dire
que c'est la moins mauvaise manière d' à
proximus premier ordre une réalité
physique du moment mais on a oublié le
du moment dans la sphère si on avait
gardé le du moment aujourd'hui on dirait
bien voilà avec le du moment qui est
juste le capital et le travail ça marche
plus donc il faut qu on réinjecte
d'urgence d'autres trucs dans nos
modèles sauf que à ce moment vous
tomberiez sur quelque chose qui ne vous
autorise pas la démagogie et
il se trouve que 1 des processus qui
s'est passé avec l'économie et qui ne se
passe pas du tout avec la physique du
reste au grand dam des physiciens
c'est que vous avez cette proximité
d'aucun dirait presque une collusion
entre le monde économique et le monde
politique et qui n'a pu se développer
que justement parce que en démocratie
comme l'économie est un système sans
limite
ça va bien de se marier avec le système
politique
ça pose pas de problème bon vous avez
jamais suivi un cours de physique
politique alors qu'il existe des cours
d'économie politique partout non donc
cesser cette ce rapprochement entre les
sphères du pouvoir est une discipline
appelons la comme on veut pas
scientifique ou scientifique peu importe
qu'on appelle l'économie a notamment été
favorisée par une approximation aux
premières heures plus valable
aujourd'hui et qu'on devrait faire
sauter si on ne s'occupait que
d'orthodoxie académique sauf que si on
ne s'occupe que d'orthodoxie académique
on perd la proximité avec les cercles du
pouvoir et la capacité d' influence
qu'on peut avoir au nom de sa discipline
donc mon sentiment c'est qu'il se
passera la prédiction j'ai pu si ces
bords aux planques là qui disait vous
vous attendez que vos ennemis meurent
vous n'arrivez pas à les convaincre
je pense que malheureusement l'économie
classique c'est exactement ça qui va se
passer pour l'essentiel oui bonjour vous
ne parlez pas de la surpopulation dans
votre exposé est ce que finalement une
des solutions serait pas d'être
raisonnable et de fer drastiquement
beaucoup moins d'enfants
c'est un débat extrêmement difficile
parce que dans cette affaire il ya le
raisonnement analytique que vous pouvez
tenir donc là la réponse est oui
après il ya le raisonnement humain que
vous pouvez tenir parce que en fait vous
vous rendez compte
vous avez l'air un peu plus jeune que
moi la bbc vous vous rendrez compte
quand vous commencerez à gagner quelques
années que la partie analytique des
hommes même les hommes l'espèce
mystérieux s'il en est pour une femme
en fait c'est quand même une partie
secondaire de leur individus et que les
hommes restent aux faits
spécimens au sens large de chair et de
sang et de sentiments et donc c'est des
tas de trucs pour lesquels oui sur le
papier ça semble raisonnable en fait
dans la pratique c'est un débat qui ne
s'incarne jamais qu il ya plusieurs
raisons à ça la première c'est qu'on est
quand même câble est biologiquement pour
avoir envie de se reproduire
c'est quand même un truc qui nous vient
du fond des âges la deuxième c'est qu'il
n'y a pas de chef mondial pour organiser
ça donc on est renvoyé au traité de
westphalie et au fait que les pays sont
souverains et donc ils font ce qu'ils
veulent
là est qu'une fois que vous avez les
pays qui font ce qu'ils veulent sur leur
sol et des mouvements migratoires vous
pouvez propager quelques quelque sorte
une élévation de population qui prend
place ici pour la transformer en une
augmentation de la consommation qui
valent à l'immigration dans les pays de
l' ocde est une très bonne manière
d'élever la consommation d'énergie des
migrants je t'aime bien est la dernière
chose c'est que comme le disait le braz
j'ai croisé ya pas longtemps une
émission on était tous les deux invités
on se met d'accord sur quelques chiffres
moi je vais vous le dire autrement ça
dépend si vous avez dans cette histoire
envie de durer et 50 ans ou deux
millénaires à ce moment la stabilisation
se fait pas au même niveau donc c'est ça
n'empêche pas cette affaire de prendre
des mesures sans regret les mesures sans
regret c'est quoi c'est à chaque fois
que c'est possible essayer de remplacer
le désir d'enfant par quelque chose qui
apporte presque les mêmes satisfactions
j'allais dire comment ça on va pas
remplacer un enfant parent par une
peluche
ce que je vis c'est pas exactement ça
vous avez deux processus qui encore
aujourd'hui contribue quand même de
manière non négligeable à la hausse
démographique qui sont d'abord les
familles qui s'agrandissent alors que le
couple et en particulier la femme n'a
pas vraiment demander ça
donc la diffusion de la contraception
reste une bonne idée la diffusion de
l'éducation des femmes
de ce point de vue reste aussi une bonne
idée beaucoup de gens confondent la
montée du niveau éducatif avec la hausse
du pib moi je dis non non la hausse du
pib c'est pas le sujet ce qui s' est la
hausse du niveau éducatif
ce qui soit dit en passant derrière pose
problème quand derrière on dit vous
allez monter le niveau d'éducation est
gardée de pib consent et la troisième
chose c'est les systèmes de retraite
parce que vous avez beaucoup
d'augmentation des cellules familiales
qui prennent place dans des pays dans
lesquels n'y a pas de système de
retraites organisée et donc c'est votre
assurance vieillesse
vous dites sur les 25 enfants et demi
que je fais il y en a bien qui va
s'occuper d'eux les deux jours donc ça
c'est vous avez là des modes d'action
qui à défaut de ramener la population à
quelque chose qui serait soutenable
quelques milliers d'années
en tout cas vous permettre de limiter
aujourd'hui la hausse notamment là où
elle ne procure pas de bonheur
intense et puis après vous avez un
deuxième sujet qui va fuir les quelques
cheveux gris dans cette salle faut
laisser mourir les vieux vous avec trois
manières de diminuer la taille de la
population à naissance donner enfin je
veux dire est que de manière pardon
c'est de diminuer les dépenses ou
d'augmenter les morts oui la taille de
la population ces gens vivent donc il ya
deux manières et une des manières
d'augmenter les morts s'est pas
prolongée les lieux qui par ailleurs
coûte très très cher en ressources en
argent donc en ressources à la
collectivité au détriment des jeunes a
rigolé par devant aujourd'hui c'est
exactement dans un univers contraint je
leur dis vous pouvez pas donner plus à
jacques sans démunir un peu paul donc
aujourd'hui le fait de dire qu'on va
mobiliser des moyens médicaux lourds au
profit des gens en fin de vie
c'est avoir dit qu on donnera moins aux
jeunes c'est un peu brutal le dire comme
ça malheureusement c'est une vérité
bonsoir je suis j'ai bien aimé votre
exposé dont je partage les je voulais
mon jeu rebondit sur cette question qui
en fait je voulais vous poser c'est vous
n'avez pas parlé effectivement de logos
de l'augmentation de la population et
c'est vous c'était le prémisse que la
population restait content constant
attendant techno nommé dans les schémas
que vous avez montré des voix là alors
donc diminuer les la population pour
être encore plus cynique c'est il
faudrait une bonne guerre ou une
révolution
donc je veux pas la paix sinon mieux
je vous assure que la peste c'est mieux
et parce que au moyen âge en fait j'ai
un ami historien qui pensent très
profondément que ce qui a permis le
renouveau économique de la renaissance
et les grandes pestes du moyen-âge et
alors le lien pour lui est le suivant
mais je trouve que c'est séduisant en
termes d'explication on avait construit
des moulins pour nourrir la population
au moyen âge et puis à ilha grande peste
qui divise la population par deux à ce
moment vous vous retrouvez avec moitié
moins de moulins nécessaires pour
nourrir la population et l'autre moitié
des moulins peut être mis au service des
soufflet de forge de la proto industrie
etc et
lui soutient et je le redis c'est assez
séduisant comme explication que c'est la
grande peste qui a permis l'essor et
l'expansion qui a suivi au moment de la
renaissance et du premier développement
industriel qui n'est pas la révolution
de 1800 mais qui a pris place avant
grâce à ce premier rapport d'énergie
mécanique
donc c'est pour ça que je disais en
taquinant la balle a dit c'est mieux
parce que ça laisse les moyens intacte
mais sinon oui si on en revient à ce
débat difficile il ya que trois manières
de faire mourir les gens c'est la famine
la maladie et la guerre ce que j'ai
proposé tout à leur laisser mourir les
vieux c'est la moins désagréable des
trois manières oui qu'est ce que vous
pensez de l'énergie au thorium
alors j'en pense que dans l'est dans les
équations que j'ai montré là il ya deux
manières de répondre à une question qui
est qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
l'énergie machin je parle pour moi mais
ce que je vais vous proposer une
explication plus générale il ya une
première manière qui est de dire est ce
que ça va être un contributeur
significatif
odf à la déformation des tendances que
j'ai exposé avant là la réponse est non
après il ya une deuxième manière de
répondre qui est est ce que dans un
monde dans lequel mes ressources sont
contraintes
la petite quantité d'argent parce qu'on
parle pas d'une quantité d'argent
phénoménale à ce stade que je mettrais
là dedans c'est plus intéressant que ce
que je pourrais en faire ailleurs
et à ce moment la réponse est oui alors
je vais répondre à la deuxième version
de la question la deuxième version de la
question se présente deux pour moi comme
suit je pense qu'aujourd'hui dans
l'argent qu'on est en train de mettre
dans la filière nucléaire on peut
arrêter iter demain matin ça sert
strictement à rien enfin aux échelles de
temps qui m'intéresse ça sert à rien
facile on va faire plaisir aux gens qui
bossent dessus mais l'utilité sociale
est nulle part contre de s'intéresser
sérieusement à la quatrième génération
de fission ça c'est pas complètement
stupide et dans la quatrième génération
si j'étais maître du monde
la manière dont je me prendrais est la
suivante je dirai au cea
vous arrêtez tout de suite astrid ou
plus exactement vous arrêtez tout de
suite de dire que vous avez déjà la
solution parce que je m'appelle corinne
lepage en 15 secondes
astrid est mort je vous dis c'est super
phénix en or en v2 terminé n'existait
plus donc la manière dont il faut s'y
prendre à mon avis c'est de dire nous
n'avons pas la science infuse
donc on va faire au niveau européen à
moi c'est mon avis surtout que l'europe
a besoin d'un projet une version
accélérée du forum cas de gêne donc
j'oublie la terre entière là parce
qu'avec la terre entière on n'avance pas
donc je fais un truc accéléré avec
quelques pays qui ont vraiment envie du
forum cas de gêne dans les dessins qui
existent j'en prends quatre ou cinq par
12 4 ou 5 je vire tout ce qui est du
graphite dans le coeur façon moi j'ai
pas envie de revivre dans le coeur tout
s'est enfin tout un tas de trucs et sur
les quelques dessins qui me paraissent
avoir leur chance
je fais un proto en maîtrise d'oeuvre
délégué total des pays qui acceptent
d'en avoir un sur leur sol et je n'ai
pas les emmerder avec le fait une
tranche de mandarine viendra du japon
l'autre tranche de mandarine viendra
grande bretagne la troisième de chez
paou avec les vis et les boulons qui
doivent être fabriqués dans des gens
quand ils les accords syndicaux ne sais
pas quoi
on s'occupe pas de ce genre de truc là
le pays prend en maîtrise d'oeuvre
délégué total et vudu blood et les pros
tôt pour être sûr qu'il y aura pas un
accident industriel quelque part qui
vous empêchera d'avoir le résultat
si vous faites ça rase et un programme
qui coûte le même prix khiter sauf que
lui a une petite chance de servir à
quelque chose d'ici la fin du siècle
ça va pas être un game challenger de
premier ordre
j'insiste enfin ou plus exactement sur
la deuxième moitié du xxième siècle si
on s'y prend maintenant crash programme
ça pourrait mais sur la première moitié
c'est beaucoup trop tard sur la première
moitié
la solution aux problèmes que j'ai
évoquée si je reste physique pas
économique
ça s'appelle d'abord les économies
d'énergie même si ça doit être un peu
excessif et ensuite ça s'appelle un mix
de nerfs et de nucléaire selon le
contexte géographique dans lequel vous
vous trouvez les nerfs c'est beaucoup
plus facile à mettre en oeuvre si vous
avez des grandes surfaces de bois et de
montagne par personne ou des grandes
quantités de soleil le soleil la
concentration le solaire à concentration
on l'a par exemple est parti ça c'est un
truc qui me paraît plus intéressant que
le photovoltaïque parce que vous
internaliser enfin vous supprimez
d'intermittence plus exactement c'est ça
qui vous coûte cher avec le pv mémé et
il faut avoir un indicateur de gestion
qui vous permet de choisir entre ces
solutions et lui il dépend en gros des
capitaux nécessaires pour avoir un
kilowattheures d'énergie décarbonée et
ça ça dépend énormément de la géographie
locale
voilà mais le donc je vous ai donné le
big picture et dans cette affaire-là
explorer la filière au thorium ça me
paraît pas complètement idiot mais ça va
pas être un game challenger encore une
fois pour l'ensemble du problème à
l'échelle d'une génération ou deux une
dernière question très très rapide
oui merci pour votre vulgarisation je
suis une ancienne scientifique donc ça
me permet de me remettre dans le bain
mais j'ai bien noté la complexité
systémique
j'ai noté aussi parce que j'en avais pas
conscience de la halle c'est l'énergie
et le réchauffement qui a un impact sur
l'économie et non pas l'un vers ce mal
et au delà de la maîtrise de la
population qui est un des paramètres
j'aimerais vous entendre un petit peu
sûrs d une synthèse gérait des pistes
d'actions soit au niveau mondial
européen étatique territoire et humain
un petit peu une synthèse parce qu'en
fait je suis un petit peu resté sur ma
faim sur nextep ya pas de ce soir vous
avez déjà évoqué plusieurs pistes dans
les rues il n'y a pas de solution
miracle sur le next up
donc la synthèse vous la ferez pas ce
que je peux vous proposer ces quelques
lectures donc le chiffre project a sorti
il ya maintenant six mois aux ordres de
grandeur et c'est ça parce que c'était
juste avant les élections aux éditions
odile jacob
un livre qui s'appelle des carbonneau
avec un point d'exclamation dans lequel
vous avez l'embryon de ce que pourrait
être un plan d'action économique
européen sur la question
sébastien thèse c'est déjà 150 pages la
manière dont on s'y est pris est assez
simple on a dit on à décomposer les
émissions européennes par grands
morceaux et on a dit si on veut être
sérieux sur chacun de ses morceaux on ne
peut pas passer à côté d'une mesure
principale sans laquelle il n'y a pas
une chance qu'on échappe alors nous on a
pris d'entrée climat pour quand on
appris l'entrée climat on aurait pu
prendre l'entrée approvisionnements
parce que aujourd'hui dans le débat
si vous parlez climat vous êtes écoutez
si vous parlez approvisionnement on vous
dit mais vous raconter n'importe quoi il
ya encore quarante ans de pétrole qu'est
ce que vous venez m'emmerder et le temps
qu'on montre les courbes que je vous ai
montré sur le fait que le pic
d'approvisionnement en pétrole en europe
était déjà passé depuis dix ans de toute
façon les gens sont passés à autre chose
donc si vous voulez leur part les
approvisionnements en leur expliquant
que même s'il croit pas au climat de
toute façon on est déjà dans la seringue
sur la décrue subi d'approvisionnement
fossiles et donc on est déjà parti pour
une baisse du pib structurelles je vais
dire du pib devrait vous êtes perdus en
plus vous avez d'économistes contre vous
donc ce n'est même pas la peine de ram
et donc c'est pour ça qu'on a pris
l'entrée climat et dans l'entré clé mais
c'est pareil que l'énergie soit pour
l'agriculture on a pris les gros paquets
des émissions européennes et on a dit
pour chaque paquet donc je propose une
ou deux mesures qui soient une la
première mesure à mettre en oeuvre
de telle sorte qu'au total je me
retrouve avec moins de 10 donc la presse
fait pas le tri à ma place si elles en
parlent ce qui a très bien marché pour
nous une pleine page dans les échos où
ils ont détaillé les neuf mesures pour
vous donner un exemple dans
l'électricité la production électrique
au charbon c'est les deux tiers des
émissions européennes de production
d'électricité donc on a une mesure à une
seule c'est supprimer charbon
pour le remplacer par du low carbon et
donc ou bien vous n'avez rien contre le
nucléaire et vous faites du nucléaire ou
bien vous avez tous contre le nucléaire
et vous faites des éoliennes et des
panneaux solaires ça vous coûtera 10
fois l'argent mais c'est pas grave on
s'en fout faites le en ce qui concerne
je prendre un autre sujet beaucoup plus
d'ésotérique les transports en ce qui
concerne les transports on a dit il faut
absolument limiter à 2 litres aux cent
tout véhicule neuf vendu en europe à
partir de 2030
moi je ne crois pas à la voiture
électrique pour avoir 30 millions de
voitures en france par une seconde
par contre je pense que la personne qui
vient travailler ici à la cantine en
venant du sud de grenoble
il va se passer encore du temps avant
qu'elle puisse nécessairement accéder à
un logement auprès des transports en
commun tout et voilà donc il faut
absolument offrir de la mobilité
accessible à ces gens là que sinon ils
sont pas contents ils se révoltent ils
ont raison est la meilleur moyen c'est
de refaire des deux chevaux dont vous
faites des voitures qui vont pas vite
qu'ils sont pas puissante qui sont pas
lourdes et la masse et la puissance
étant fortement abaisser la consommation
aussi vous avez des astuces après pour
les hybrides et mais ce n'est pas la
peine de faire des chars d'assaut
hybride ça c'est ça résoudra pas le
problème non plus on a par exemple une
autre mesure dans l'industrie lourde qui
consiste à dire qu'il faut diviser les
flux par deux fers de la capture du co2
un peu mieux recycler etc
enfin voilà donc on a donc cédé mesure
un peu on n'a pas dit qu'on avait une
semaine pour les mettre en oeuvre et à
chaque fois on a cubes et les
investissements qu'ils allaient en
regard de la mesure parce qu'en général
ce qui bloque quand vous devez passer à
l'action dans notre monde dans lequel
c'est l'euro qui reste l'alpha et
l'oméga de tout ce qui se décide c'est
que même si vous avez bien compris mon
discours comme quoi la macroéconomie
aujourd'hui ne nous sert à rien ou plus
exactement si on va les rapprocher des
problèmes physiques divergent par contre
la micro économie c'est-à-dire comment
jaloux l'effort et à qui je demande de
mettre son argent sur la table
si vous n'êtes pas capable de parler ce
langage là vous n'existez pas
dans le débat sur l'action et donc on
s'est invité dans ce débat sur l'action
en quantifiant les investissements qui
étaient nécessaires pour avancer sur les
pistes qu'on propose donc à les lire ce
petit livre qui coûte très très cher je
crois 8 ou 9 euros et vous verrez un
embryon de réponse à la question alors
circonscrit à l'europe
mais bon après ça ça vous donnera le
schéma général
je suis vraiment désolé pour toutes les
questions qui n'ont pas pu être posée
mais monsieur jancovici a rendez vous
avec la sncf et le temps il parle
maintenant par toujours leur voilà donc
on le remercie pour sa présentation et
merci à vous d'être venu
[Applaudissements]